les questions au Gouvernement la
première d'entre elles va être posée par
Madame Isabelle Santiago pour le groupe
socialiste merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
il ne sait pas passer un jour cette
semaine sans que l'Azerbaïdjan ne viole
le cesser le feu de novembre 2020 tire
sur les positions militaires ou cibles
civiles en Arménie et dans le haut
Caraba la terrorisation du peuple
arménien continue dans l'indifférence de
la communauté internationale avec le
blocus du corridor de la Chine le haut
karaba est devenu une prison à ciel
ouvert 120
000 Arméniens dont 30 000 enfants
risquent à chaque instant leur vie ne
fermons pas les yeux depuis six mois ces
populations manquent de tout peine à
survivre le gaz et l'électricité sont
coupées les biens de première nécessité
comme la nourriture et les médicaments
ne peuvent plus être acheminées pendant
ce temps-là l'Europe accroisse ses
importations de gaz depuis l'Azerbaïdjan
les crises majeures que nous traversons
en Europe ne peuvent détourner la
situation du peuple arménien que nous
devons regarder avec la réalité en face
la France a un lien historique et
fraternel avec l'Arménie il est du
devoir de notre nation d'agir madame la
ministre la France doit soutenir
l'adoption sans délai d'une résolution
du Conseil de sécurité à l'ONU visant à
rétablir la libre circulation entre
l'Arménie et le haut Karaba et faire
respecter l'accord triparti signer le
cessez-le-feu du 9 novembre 2020 il
convient de demander la mise en place
d'une force d'interposition et de donner
enfin les moyens à l'Arménie de se
défendre à cette même tribune le 3
novembre 1896 Jean Jaurès dénonçait le
prélude du génocide des Arméniens de
1915 alors une nouvelle fois
indignons-nous et réagissons je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à Madame
Catherine colonn a ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Santiago merci de votre question madame
la députée qui m'offre l'occasion de
rappeler que aucun pays aucun pays ne
fait autant que le nôtre en vue d'un
accord de paix entre l'Arménie et son
voisin et je le redis aucun pays n'est
assez coté autant que nous le sommes
nous sommes au côté de l'Arménie en vue
d'une paix juste la France l'a encore
démontré lorsque le président de la
République s'est mobilisé le 1er juin
akissino en marge du sommet de la
communauté politique européenne
en réunissant le Premier ministre
pachinian le président Alif avec le
chancelier schols et le président du
Conseil européen une nouvelle réunion
madame la député aura lieu à Bruxelles
le 21 juillet et nous saluons par
ailleurs les efforts de médiation de
notre partenaire américain avec lequel
nous nous coordonnons étroitement nous
sommes aussi aux côtés de l'Arménie
quand il faut faire baisser les tensions
sur le terrain et donc nous l'avons
démontré lorsque je me suis rendu à la
fin du mois d'avril pour encourager les
deux dirigeants à trouver un accord de
paix aussi bien en Arménie quand ça se
ainsi que à la frontière auprès de la
Mission d'observation de l'Union
européenne dont l'existence doit
grandement à notre pays et qui joue un
rôle extrêmement utile pour apaiser les
tensions nous sommes enfin aux côtés de
l'Arménie dans le soutien humanitaire
sujet qui a été évoqué lors du sommet à
kissina au premier juin tout comme a été
évoqué bien sûr la conséquence du
blocage illégal du corridor de la Chine
illégal puisque ainsi il a décidé la
Cour internationale de justice le 22
février dernier et nous demandons à
laservation de cette décision donc vous
le voyez madame la députée nous sommes
aux côtés de l'Arménie et des Arméniens
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre
madame Santiago oui il me reste quelques
secondes juste pour dire que j'entends
évidemment l'action qui est menée on est
tous mobilisés la seule chose c'est que
ça fait 6 mois et que là il s'agit
évidemment de survie du peuple et donc
du coup c'est important qu'on puisse le
rappeler à l'occasion de ces QG en
totale soutien avec le peuple arménien
je vous remercie ma chère collègues et
je recevrai dans les prochaines semaines
mon homologue de l'Assemblée nationale
arménienne qui viendra en visite à
l'Assemblée nationale et nous pourrons
nous le rappeler notre soutien
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Yoann Gillet
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
cette française sur dix sont favorables
à un référendum sur la politique
migratoire ils sont 80% à demander de la
fermeté en la matière les Français
subissent une immigration dérégulée
massive et anarchique qui a de lourdes
conséquences voici 30 ans que les
Français sont privés de leurs droits
d'être consultés sur le sujet les
Français n'en peuvent plus de cette
immigration massive qui change le visage
de notre pays et vecteur d'insécurité
les Français ne veulent plus la financer
ils en ont pensé de voir des demandeurs
d'asile ou même des étrangers sous OCC
remplir les pages des journaux non pas
pour des choses positives mais pour des
meurtres et des agressions quotidiennes
pourquoi donc avez-vous toujours refusé
de donner la parole au peuple sur ce
sujet pourquoi monsieur le ministre vous
semblez patiner sur ce sujet majeur un
sujet qui ici était pris comme le
taureau par les cornes ferait économiser
des dizaines de milliards par an cela
devrait par ailleurs intéresser le
ministre des comptes publics et votre
gouvernement à la rue financièrement qui
rappelons-le détient le record de dette
avec 3000 milliards d'euros si vous vous
attaquiez enfin au sujet de
l'immigration les Français pourraient
aussi retrouver leur tranquillité cela
devrait guider votre action chaque matin
car votre devoir monsieur le ministre
est de protéger ce qui ne peuvent le
faire eux-mêmes et notamment les
compatriotes les plus fragiles
qu'attendez-vous pour agir nous avons
nous un projet déjà prêt clé en main
celui de Marine Le Pen nous vous donnons
monsieur le ministre nous vous donnons
notre accord pour le copier-coller vous
pourriez ainsi vous attaquer aux droits
du sol et à la délinquance en expulsant
les délinquants étrangers réformez l'ame
réformer le droit d'asile bref vous
pourriez avec le projet de Marine Le Pen
répondre aux attentes légitimes des
Français et tourner la page du manque de
courage politique vous pourriez tourner
le dos à tous ceux qui se succèdent
depuis des décennies et se contentent
d'assister à l'ensemble logement de
notre pays sans rien faire
en détournant le regard alors Monsieur
le Ministre quand allez-vous enfin agir
et nous présenter quelque chose de
solide pour protéger les Français la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
je voudrais faire deux remarques
la première c'est de vous remercier
d'avoir retrouvé enfin un peu de décence
la première c'est de vous remercier de
ne pas avoir sauté sur votre téléphone
votre clavier pour dénoncer je ne sais
quel
je ne sais quel défaut du fonctionnement
du gouvernement pour pouvoir appuyer vos
thèse fonder sur la peur votre question
d'actualité avons-nous été demandé avant
que vous vous rendiez compte de l'énorme
de l'innommable et de l'insupportable de
vos réactions le jour de ces événements
absolument désastreux d'Annecy pour
lequel je veux avoir aujourd'hui
quelques mots
d'ailleurs les victimes ne vous
intéressent pas vous n'avez pas un mot
pour les enfants ce n'est pas un moment
pour les parents pendant cette question
d'actualité
si finalement l'histoire ne se déroule
pas comme l'imagine Madame Le Pen et
tout le rassemblement national et je
peux vous dire que c'est le dégoût qui
nous inspire quand vous parlez de ce
sujet
deuxièmement monsieur le député vous
parlez de l'appel au peuple mais je vous
ferai remarquer que Madame Le Pen a déjà
été jugé sur son programme par deux fois
elle a été battue avec ce présidentiel
je vais vous faire remarquer depuis que
50 ans que le Front national pour
l’adversité le refus de l'altérité et la
haine à chaque fois les Français lui
disent non et c'est un grand peuple que
le peuple français
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Antoine Armand
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la Première ministre madame la Première
ministre jeudi un peu avant 10h sur le
jardin du paquet à Annecy un homme est
entré dans une aire de jeux
et à poignarder des enfants
jusque dans leur poussette
depuis nos pensées sont avec Peter 22
mois avec Ennio et Alba 2 ans avec ETI 3
ans ainsi qu'avec manuel 72 ans et
Youssouf 78 ans nous pensons à eux
tous
tous sont en vie tous sont en vie grâce
aux prodigieux remparts d'humanité qui
s'est immédiatement dressé contre la
barbarie ce rempart se rend pas il a le
visage d'Henri le visage dépassant et
des agents d'entretien qui se sont
interposés il a le visage des policiers
d'Annecy des militaires des pompiers du
Samu de la sécurité civile il a le
visage des soignants d'Annecy de
Grenoble et de Genève et aujourd'hui
devant la représentation nationale je
leur dis nous leur disons merci
dès jeudi madame la Première ministre
vous vous êtes rendu avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur puis le lendemain le
président de la République est venu à
Annecy exprimer la reconnaissance de
toute la nation dimanche anestienne
année sien nous nous sommes rassemblés
fraternellement pour partager cette
gratitude cette gratitude qui est plus
forte qui sera toujours plus forte que
les mensonges et les parades des
récupérateurs sordides et des
opportunistes de la haine
mais cette gratitude ne suffira pas face
aux questions qui nous hante nous aurons
besoin de réponses en matière de
mécanisme européen d'asile de sécurité
de proximité de psychiatrie pour cela
nous avons besoin que la justice fasse
son travail madame la Première ministre
pouvait nous donc nous communiquer les
derniers éléments de l'enquête je vous
remercie merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la
[Applaudissements]
parole
la prof
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Antoine Armand nous avons tous été
frappés de stupeur face à l'attaque
sauvage dont ont été victime des tout
petits enfants jeudi dernier à Annecy et
nous étions ensemble monsieur le député
en effet quelques heures après cette
attaque avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin mes pensées vont en
premier lieu aux familles de ces
petits-enfants à ses petits-enfants
également aux autres victimes adultes de
cette terrible attaque et je voudrais à
mon tour rendre hommage remercier les
forces de l'ordre la police nationale la
police municipale
qui est intervenu
donc ces forces de l'ordre qui ont pu
intervenir quelques minutes après le
début de cette attaque et qui ont pu
neutraliser cette agresseur et je
voudrais également rendre hommage aux
forces de secours qui ont été en
première ligne face à ce drame absolu de
tout petits-enfants blessés et qui avec
les soignants ont su prendre en charge
ces petits-enfants et aujourd'hui
heureusement leur vie n'est plus en
danger donc je pense que vraiment
l'heure est à l'émotion naturellement
l'enquête doit permettre de faire toute
la lumière toute la lumière sur le
parcours de cette agresseur toute la
lumière sur ses motivations mais ne
mélangeant pas tout ne récupérons pas
des drames épouvantables comme ceux que
nous avons vécu et dans la sérénité
apportons des réponses à nos concitoyens
que nous devons plus que jamais protégé
je vous remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien
Saintoul du groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame
Schiappa ce n'est pas tant une question
que je veux poser à cet instant c'est
une supplication que je formule
démissionner des missionné séance
tenantes permettez-nous de croire un
instant que le mot de responsabilité
peut avoir du sens pour un membre du
gouvernement la création et
l'attribution de l'argent du fond
Marianne sont d'ores et déjà une immense
tâche que seul votre démission peut
laver quelle que soit l'hypothèse
retenue que vous ayez fait preuve de
légèreté d'incompétence ou d'un cynisme
révoltant pour répondre politiquement de
vos actes il faut démissionner et si
vous vous obstinez la première ministre
doit vous congédier
le scandale du fond Marianne est
proprement inouï et intolérable dans un
régime démocratique vous avez permis et
peut-être même organisé
l'instrumentalisation de l'assassinat
ignoble de Samuel Paty
ce crime abominable qui voulait mettre à
l'épreuve l'unité de notre peuple vous
l'avez utilisé pour cibler des
adversaires politiques pour détourner
des moyens de l'État au service d'une
campagne électorale et pour ce type
endier de prétendues experts de la lutte
contre l'islamisme tout confirme ses
faits les auditions publiques de la
commission d'enquête au Sénat le rapport
de l'inspection de l'administration et
la démission de Monsieur Gravel l'homme
liche de Monsieur Valls à qui vous aviez
confié comme une récompense le soin de
lutter contre la radicalisation tout est
lamentable dans ce scandale y compris la
tentative de diversion impudante que
vous avez organisé en posant pour un
magazine de charme comment la honte ne
vous a-t-elle pas enseveli comment
soutenez-vous encore le regard de vos
pères du gouvernement et de la
représentation nationale je vous en
adjure madame Schiappa démissionné
la parole
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Sonia bac S ministre chargé de la
citoyenneté
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés et Monsieur le
Député saint Toul visiblement vous
ignorez ce qu'est l'État de droit dans
un état de droit c'est la justice qui
juge ce n'est ni le tribunal populaire
ni les députés
et la justice et la justice vous le
savez tous la justice a pris en main ce
dossier et la l'île du gouvernement a
été claire depuis le début transparence
et réactivité avec Gérald Darmanin nous
avons saisi des connaissances des
premières alertes sur le sujet
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît nous
avons saisi avec Gérald Darmanin dès les
premières alertes sur ce sujet
l'inspection générale de
l'administration et la procureur de la
République de Paris sur le fondement de
l'article 40 le premier rapport de l'IGA
qui a été rendu public mais en évidence
des erreurs voire même des fautes sur le
suivi administratif de ce dossier
l'enquête judiciaire est ouverte il ne
nous appartient pas et il ne vous
appartient pas de la commenter mais
mesdames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député saint Toul nous ne
sommes dupe de rien certains ici veulent
se réjouissent de cette affaire qu'ils
instrumentalisent à souhait dont vous
êtes pour mettre à terre l'esprit de
cette initiative lancé après le terrible
attentat de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine qui
nous a tous terriblement choqué
en salissant l'action engagée de Marlène
Schiappa sur le sujet vous aimeriez
au-delà du fond Marianne mettre un terme
à la politique publique de contredis
pour de contrediscours républicains de
lutte contre les séparatistes
qui est mené par l'État depuis les
vagues d'attentats qui ont meurtri notre
pays en matière d'Islam radicale les
discours les plus violents les plus
dangereux ne sont plus dans les mosquées
ils sont sur les réseaux sociaux et je
veux saluer l'action du secrétariat
général du cipdr qui tous les jours
combat ses menaces au service de la
France je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
panifiouse pour le groupe yote
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé s'il y a bien une
préoccupation majeure et ancienne que
nous entendons tous les jours au cœur de
nos territoires c'est la difficulté
d'accès aux soins les collectivités se
mobilisent pour y répondre la région
Occitanie par exemple s'est engagée
activement en recrutant des médecins
pour les territoires soudés c'est le
dispositif ma santé ma région à
l'Assemblée nationale un groupe
transpartisan sur les déserts médicaux
c'est constitué porteur de nombreuses
propositions d'autres initiatives
parlementaires se multiplient les lois
katabi et risques viennent d'être
adoptés et aujourd'hui nous examinons la
proposition de loi Valtou nous nous
réjouissons forcément que des
propositions de loi soient examinées
même lorsqu'elles constituent des
charges pour l'État preuve que le
travail parlementaire lorsqu'il est
respecté madame la Présidente est utile
néanmoins l'accumulation de ces
initiatives interrogent sur la cohérence
et la stratégie du gouvernement cela
interroge sur les moyens que vous êtes
prêts à investir pour garantir l'accès
aux soins de tous sur vos priorités et
sur l'urgence à agir vous me répondrez
certainement numérique à Perthus
pratiques avancée assistant médicaux
Ségur toutes ces décisions sont
positives et à mettre à votre crédit
mais c'est encore insuffisant et en
attendant les déserts médicaux
s'aggravent les conditions d'accueil
mais aussi de travail dans les hôpitaux
dans les EHPAD se dégradent les délais
de prise en charge s'allongent à la
veille de la période estivale les
urgences ferment déjà dans trop de
territoires il faut aller plus loin on
ne peut pas attendre 10 ans que les
nouveaux médecins arrivent tout n'a pas
été fait tout n'a pas été essayé en
termes plus clair n'est-il pas tant de
s'engager sur une grande loi Santé et
Territoires et de faire de la santé une
priorité nationale je vous remercie
merci beaucoup coucou la parole est à
Madame Agnès Firmin le Bodo ministre
délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vous l'avez dit la santé et la
préoccupation numéro 1 de nos
concitoyens c'est bien pour ça que le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé et
que nous faisons feu de tout point pour
répondre à cette problématique le
diagnostic nous le connaissons il
n'existe pas de solution unique parce
que les besoins de santé sont différents
selon les territoires notre claque cap
est clair et cohérent depuis 2017 il a
été rappelé par le Président de la
République lors de ses vœux au
personnels soignants en janvier dernier
notre méthode aussi elle est très claire
et pragmatique avancée avec les
territoires pour les territoires et à
partir des territoires avec les
professionnels nous devons mobiliser
tous les leviers à notre disposition
créer de nouvelles solutions et les
développer pour répondre de façon
concrète à l'accès aux soins c'est le
sens du plan maison de santé pour et
professionnel que j'ai c'est hier à
Sisteron avec l'objectif de 4000 maisons
de santé pour les professionnels d'ici
2027 une maison de santé pourrait un
médecin dans une maison de santé pour
les professionnels prend 160 patients
par an en plus ce sera le sens des
mesures que nous allons développer pour
aller vers et faire le dernier kilomètre
c'est aussi mieux coopérer et élargir
les compétences des professionnels dans
le cadre de l'exercice coordonné le plan
CPTs avec un territoire 100% couvert à
la fin de l'année des professionnels
mieux organisés ce sont des patients
mieux soignés mais c'est aussi
développer le partage des compétences
au-delà des 20 nouvelles mesures et des
20 protocoles qui ont été signés c'est
le sens de la pépliste qui a été voté ce
mois dernier solliciter les soignants au
meilleur de leurs compétences tout en
rappelant que le médecin généraliste
doit rester la pierre angulaire de notre
système de santé c'est aussi simplifier
et libérer les soignants des contrats
administratives vous l'avez dit un
assistant médical c'est deux
consultations par jour disponibles pour
nos concitoyens c'est enfin fidéliser et
valoriser les professionnels c'est
redonner du sens à l'exercice
professionnel c'est valoriser les gardes
c'est respecter développer le travail de
nuit c'est aussi c'est mettre en place
la quatrième année de médecine générale
c'est aussi s'occuper de la santé et de
la sécurité des professionnels de santé
c'est aussi avancer sur la procédure des
paduds nous aurons l'occasion de
discuter merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
la parole est à Madame Sophie tailler
polluant pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la Fonction publique après
une revalorisation de 3,5% du point
d'indice l'an passé quand l'inflation se
chiffrait presque au double le
gouvernement annonce désormais une
hausse de 1,5 % quand l'inflation sur
l'année dépasse le triple asthme là
faudra-t-il tabler sur une hausse
négative l'année prochaine depuis tant
d'années on demande aux agents du
service public d'accepter sans broncher
coupe budgétaire réduction d'effectifs
et modération salariale au point qu'il
est elle ont perdu 20% de pouvoir
d'achat en 20 ans 20% tout ça accompagné
d'une dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail résultat de la logique comptable
que vous mettez en oeuvre qui produit
pour LG e une immense perte de sens et
tant de problèmes d'accès et de qualité
pour ses usagers depuis 20 ans les
agents du service public résistent
contre la logique austéritaire mais vous
les avez usées jusqu'à la corde
aujourd'hui la fonction publique est
désertée non content de les travailler
deux ans de plus malgré la pénibilité de
leurs tâches vous faites perdurer par
cette hausse ridicule le sentiment que
le service public n'est pas la solution
quoi notre société n'aurait pas les
moyens de rémunérer correctement les
femmes et les hommes qui éduquent nos
enfants qui soignent nos parents qui
gèrent nos forêts ou qui nettoient nos
rues ceux qui ont neutralisé l'agresseur
d'Annecy ou qui ont porté secours aux
victimes on ne pourrait les rémunérer
correctement ce n'est pas vrai ce n'est
pas vrai vous pourriez le faire si le
service public avait une valeur à vos
yeux alors vous allez certainement me
répondre prime et autres pacte mais le
service public a besoin qu'on croit en
lui qu'on réinvestisse pour lui dans la
durée toutes ces primes ses pattes vous
les supprimerez d'un trait de plume
lorsque vous voudrez faire de nouvelles
économies et votre trajectoire des
finances publiques nous porte à croire
qu'il n'y aura pas long à attendre
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Stanislas Guerrini ministre de
la transformation et de la fonction
publique merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée
c'est la question de la responsabilité
est-ce que le somme à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités pour répondre aux
préoccupations première des agents de la
fonction publique et comme les autres
Français sont concernés par les
questions de pouvoir d'achat et je vous
le dis en ayant sur cette question
toujours prime et responsabilités je
suis le ministre de la Fonction publique
qui a le plus augmenté le point d'indice
l'année dernière et qu'il a fait bien
avantage que toutes les majorités
précédentes c'était une augmentation
historique il n'avait pas été
revalorisée ainsi depuis 37 années
madame la députée et nous sommes cette
année encore à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités j'ai reçu hier
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
et j'ai pu faire des annonces fortes sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat et de la
rémunération de nos agents publics j'ai
annoncé d'abord que nous allions cette
année encore mobiliser la même enveloppe
salariale à la revalorisation des
salaires des fonctionnaires que nous
avions fait l'année dernière c'était
historique et nous renouvelons cet
effort cette année nous allons faire
très concrètement d'abord en augmentant
la rémunération indiscer c'est-à-dire le
fixe des fonctionnaires de
2,5%, ça sera 1,5% de revalorisation du
point d'Alice dès juillet et des
distributions de points pour tous les
fonctionnaires des janvier 2024 mais
j'assume aussi que nous devons
concentrer nos efforts sur les agents
qui ont les basses à l'air et les
classes moyennes de la fonction publique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle à ces
mesures là j'ai ajouté des mesures
spécifiques pour accompagner les bas
salaire pour désécraser les grilles
justement pour donner la progressivité
et nous y consacrerons plus de 600
millions d'euros sur la fin de l'année
et en effet j'assume aussi de répondre
dans les médias à la question du pouvoir
d'achat et d'apporter une prime de
pouvoir d'achat aux agents de la
fonction publique les moins bien
rémunérés la moitié des fonctionnaires
recevront ont dès septembre une prime de
800 euros brut à 300 euros brut sur leur
compte en banque et c'est une réponse
immédiate aux questions de pouvoir
d'achat vous le voyez nous prenons nos
responsabilités cette majorité prend ses
responsabilités merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre monsieur collègue allez-y
quand ce gouvernement décide de donner
la possibilité aux propriétaires
d'augmenter les loyers de 3,5% et que
d'un autre côté les fonctionnaires
n'augmentent ne sont augmentés que de
1,5
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Anne-Cécile violente pour le groupe
horizon
merci madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer il est des
événements auxquels notre mandat nous
confronte dont nous ne trouvons les mots
à la hauteur de nos émotions
Annecy jeudi dernier trois enfants et
deux adultes étaient gravement blessés
sans oublier les témoins malgré eux de
cette tragédie tout notre soutien leur
est adressé c'est un acte d'une violence
inouïe de l'ordre de lyre représentable
de l'indicible qui nous a tous d'abord
sidéré puis particulièrement bouleversé
s'il n'existe aucune explication à un
geste d'une telle atrocité l'enquête
poursuivant son cours ne cédons pas non
plus à l'instrumentalisation et à la
démagogie
soyons ferme et juste nous faisons
pleinement confiance à la justice pour
permettre aux familles et aux victimes
de se reconstruire de ce drame indicible
souvenons-nous de celle et de ceux qui
protègent de celles et ceux qui sauvent
ce sont ces pompiers ces médecins ces
infirmiers ces policiers ces gendarmes à
qui nous devons tant sans oublier les
premiers témoins c'est héros qui ont
tenté de s'interposer oui dont Henri
sans la réactivité et le
professionnalisme de ces femmes et de
ses hommes le bilan aurait été encore
plus tragique aux côtés des forces de
l'ordre et de secours ce sont si nos
mères nos élus locaux que nous devons
soutenir et remercier ils sont eux aussi
au quotidien les premiers de cordée au
service de notre pays et de sa
protection cette solidarité cette
humanité fait la fierté de notre nation
nous leur en sommes immensément
reconnaissants notre action politique se
doit d'être à la hauteur de leur
engagement au quotidien
comment pouvons-nous accompagner
monsieur le ministre nos élus locaux
pour les aider à faire face à ces
situations d'urgence et de crise et pour
développer davantage l'Allée Verte des
structures d'accueil de ces populations
marginales je vous remercie merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Anne-Cécile violent comme l'a dit madame
la Première ministre a ainsi innable est
arrivé vous étiez sur place avec vos
collègues parlementaires avec Monsieur
le maire d'Annecy et comme l'a fait la
première ministre je veux également
remercier les policiers les policiers
municipaux et les pompiers mais aussi le
personnel de santé qui est intervenu
extrêmement rapidement et qui a permis
de le constatons de sauver la vie de ces
bébés de cette très jeune enfants en
moins de 3 minutes la police s'est
intervenue pour interpeller la saillant
et quelques secondes ont permis
d'accompagner si j'ose dire les blessés
les plus graves vers les hôpitaux de
Grenoble de Genève et
vous avez évoqué aussi le travail très
important que nous mettons en place avec
l'ensemble des collègues du gouvernement
pour aider les élus locaux pour
intervenir dans ce genre de drame quel
qu'il soit cela celui-ci est
particulièrement bien sûr grave et
touchant je veux dire que dans votre
département il y a peut-être quelque
chose qui a permis de faire sauver la
vie de ces bébés c'est justement le
travail en toute symbiose entre les
personnels les pompiers et le personnel
du ministère de la santé il y a dans ce
département une plateforme unique
lorsqu'on appelle le numéro d'urgence
pour que la régulation se fasse le plus
rapidement possible entre le SAMU entre
les pompiers et entre les autres
personnels qui sauvent la vie des
personnes je l'ai visité vous le savez
vous étiez avec moi je suis heureux de
constater que malgré ses aimants
extrêmement dramatique police pompier
SAMU médecin et puis en moins de 3
minutes intervenir et sauver la vie de
de ses enfants j'espère que cela vous
inspire à toutes et tous pour les blancs
pour les rouge pour les bleus comme on
dit dans le personnel du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour de mettre encore plus
réactif et sauver d'autres vies je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas sans su
pour le groupe GDR merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
trois fois plus de médecins généralistes
pour 100000 habitants sur l'Arc
Atlantique et sur la Côte d'Azur que
dans les départements du centre de la
France 10 fois plus d'ophtalmologiste à
Paris que dans le département du Cher
sans oublier les plus grands déserts
médicaux de notre pays que son Mayotte
la Guyane ou la Seine-Saint-Denis la
réalité ce sont des millions de nos
concitoyens qui vivent l'absence de
médecins traitant comme une violence une
injustice une rupture d'égalité d'accès
aux soins c'est le symbole d'une France
humiliée quand les déserts médicaux
avancent c'est la République qui recule
la République qui recule c'est la
progression pour la première fois depuis
1945 de la mortalité infantile et bien
sûr l'engorgement des urgences de nos
hôpitaux la position du gouvernement est
intenable madame la Première ministre
oui il fallait desserrer le numéro de
clausus mais cela ne sera pas suffisant
quand l'objectif national des dépenses
d'assurance maladie augmente moins de
l'inflation et donc ce sera moins pour
la santé demain cela ne sera pas
suffisant car d'ici 2030 le nombre de
médecins généralistes continuera de
diminuer aussi nous sommes 205 députés
issus de tous les bancs de l'arc
républicain de gauche de droite du
Centre qui proposons un pas vers la
régulation en permettant l'installation
des médecins dans les territoires qui en
manquent pour ne pas accentuer la
concentration des professionnels de
santé les députés communistes ont pour
leur part toujours porté le
conventionnement sélectif mais nous
savons qu'un petit pas vaut mieux que
1000 promesses régulation amélioration
de l'accès aux études de médecine pour
les jeunes
issus des classes modestes de la
ruralité comme des quartiers populaires
facilitation de l'intégration des
médecins diplômés hors de l'Union
Européenne écoutez les députés qui
ensemble portent des solutions
nationales et locales pour répondre à
cette exigence légitime de nos
concitoyens une exigence simple avoir un
médecin et pouvoir se écoutez enfin et
soutenez l’amendement sur la régulation
de l'installation des professionnels de
santé vous ferez nous ferons abruter
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Agnès Firma le Bodo
ministre délégué chargé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député
il n'existe pas de territoire où il y
aurait trop de médecins je ne peux pas
vous l'ex dire ça ce n'est pas vrai 87%
de la France est un désert médical la
régulation l'installation est une idée
séduisante en apparence il s'agit en
réalité d'une fausse bonne idée elle est
malheureusement inadaptée à la réalité
de notre démographie médicale elle n'a
d'ailleurs été mise en place par aucun
gouvernement ni de droite ni de gauche
par le passé et pour une bonne et simple
raison cela ne marche pas j'ai
l'occasion de le dire réguler le manque
ne résoudra malheureusement pas nos
problèmes vous qui êtes sur le terrain
comme moi vous le savez je saurai
curieuse d'abord de savoir qui est prêt
à me dire oui il y a trop de médecins
sur mon territoire au contraire c'est
une mesure qui risque de décourager les
étudiants en médecine voire de créer une
médecine à deux vitesses en encourageant
le décompventionnement des médecins et
ça je sais que vous ne le souhaitez pas
la responsabilité qui est la nôtre c'est
de dire à nos concitoyens qu'il n'y a
pas de baguette magique pour répondre à
l'accès aux soins mais ce sont des
multiples leviers d'actions sur lequel
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire tout à
l'heure et détailler ce leviers qui sont
autour de la gain de temps médical de la
formation et encore de la coopération
entre professionnels beaucoup restent à
faire bien entendu et soyez les assurés
que nous travaillons tous les jours ce
que nous proposons ce sont des solutions
concrètes pragmatiques et qui apportent
des résultats tangibles la régulation
n'apportera malheureusement rien de tout
cela
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à Madame Véronique louvagi
pour le groupe les républicains merci
madame la Présidente je veux avant tout
suite au dramatiques événements d'Annecy
renouveler mes pensées pour les victimes
et leurs familles je veux également
remercier les secours et plus
particulièrement le jeune Henri pour son
courage et saluer son sens de
l'altruisme et son civisme les Français
peuvent être fiers de l'héroïsme dont il
a fait preuve
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur le
ministre dimanche matin à l'appel du
Collectif les soulèvements de la terre
des militants écologistes ont arraché
près de Nantes des plans de muguet et
des tuyaux qui les iraient pour dénoncer
l'utilisation intensive de l'eau et du
sable
usé de violence saccagé le travail
d'autrui détérioré avec gratuitement
c'est tout simplement inacceptable aucun
prétexte aucune cause ne peuvent
justifier de détruire ainsi le pacte
républicain le militantisme est une
chose chacun a le droit d'exprimer ses
idées dans le cadre démocratique
l'activisme destructeur en est une autre
d'autant plus qu'il frappe une
profession agricole qui travaille dur et
qui souffre beaucoup par ailleurs
comment admettre comment admettre en
toute impunité des appels à la violence
des sabels au sabotages aujourd'hui les
actes sont signés revendiquées et
assumer il est d'autant plus urgent
d'agir que les prochains méfaits sont
ouvertement annoncés avec le mode
d'emploi coupez l'OSE accapareur
présente-les des méga bassines squatter
des piscines bétonner les accès aux
vannes mener des opérations contre
divers sites comme la ligne Lyon-Turin
et j'en passe monsieur le ministre vous
annonciez il y a quelques semaines une
procédure de dissolution de soulèvement
de la terre comment comprendre alors que
cette association continue à semer la
haine et la violence autour d'elle je
vous remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique porte-parole du
gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Véronique louvagi merci pour votre
question
cette association à laquelle vous faites
allusion elle prétend finalement aimer
la terre et la faire vivre avec une
forme d'activisme qui lui appartient le
député quand on aime la terre quand on
aime la terre et qu'on veut la préserver
on développe les énergies renouvelables
ce que nous faisons en multipliant par
10 le soleil est en créant 50 parties
éolien en haute mer quand on aime la
terre on fait le choix du nucléaire qui
est une énergie propre quand on aime la
terre on fait la rénovation thermique
massive des bâtiments on interdit les
véhicules électriques on arrête les
locations de passoire thermique vous
allez voir je vais vous répondre quand
on aime la terre on interdit
exploitation des fonds sous-marins à la
demande du Président de la République il
a obtenu à l'échelle mondiale pour la
réaliser des forums mondiaux pour venir
en Inde aux Forex quand on aime la terre
on prend des mesures concrètes qui sont
efficaces pour la planète et pour ceux
qui l'habitent cette association ne fait
rien de cela cette association
[Musique]
est un activisme qui est négatif et
péjoratif parce que on aide pas la terre
et on n'aime pas la terre quand
démarrage et salades quand on arrache
une muguet quand on déchiquette dessert
et quand on s'en prend aux agriculteurs
qui nous font vivre et nous nourrissent
et les spires encore mesdames la députés
on n'aime pas la terre on n'aime pas non
plus les humains lorsqu'on organise des
manifestations interdites à laquelle on
convie des militants violents étrangers
dans le seul objectif et de s'en prendre
aux forces de l'ordre et au respect de
la République madame la députée nous
partageons le Gouvernement partage votre
indignation partage vos marques de
soutien à destination de tous les
agriculteurs de ce pays s'indignent avec
vous de la présence parfois sur ces
lieux et en lien avec cette association
délu portant les chartes tricolores ou
comme elle est locaux ou comme élu
nationaux et Madame la Députée je vous
rappelle qu'à la demande du ministre de
l'intérieur un dossier a été monté en
vue de procéder à la dissolution de
cette association du solvant de la terre
si les conditions se réunies je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame louvagie mais merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre vous
n'avez finalement répondu que
partiellement un ma question parce
qu'effectivement la cause écologique est
aujourd'hui encore une fois dévoyé par
ceux qui prétendent le mieux la servir
mais ce qui est plus grave c'est que
l'État doit se faire respecter et l'État
doit faire respecter la loi si la loi
n'est pas respectée à quoi servons-nous
merci beaucoup ma chère collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Louis Boyard
pour le groupe la princesse
monsieur monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est une bombe
sanitaire qui vient d'exploser avec
l'enquête des journalistes de ver de
rage au minimum 700 000 enfants sont en
danger dans notre pays ils pourraient
respirer de l'amiante dans leurs écoles
en particulier dans les quartiers
populaires et les zones rurales cette
enquête révèle que sur près de 20 000
écoles primaires et maternelles passées
au crible 30% sont amiés 8 fois sur 10
il y avait de l'amiante dans leur salle
de classe si cet amiante est respirée
alors 30 ou 40 ans plus tard les enfants
pourraient développer un cancer monsieur
le ministre il y a urgence nous devons
savoir combien d'élèves combien de
collégiens combien de lycéens combien
d'aesh combien d'ATSEM combien de
personnels des cantines scolaires
combien d'agents d'entretien ont
respirer et continueront de respirer de
l'amiante
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur pub Ndiaye
ministre de la jeunesse et de
l'éducation
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députés Louis Boyard comme vous le savez
ce sont les collectivités qui sont en
charge du bâti scolaire et depuis 20 ans
elle sont également en charge du
désamiantage de leurs équipements
publics néanmoins le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale par définition se
préoccupe de la santé de la sécurité de
ces personnels et des élèves et ils
veillent donc particulièrement à ce que
les procédures à propos de désamiantage
soit effectivement suivie de manière
régulière et en fonction des risques
évalués les collectivités doivent
transmettre des informations relatives à
la présence d'amiante dans les locaux
scolaires afin que les chefs
d'établissement puissent prendre toutes
mesures
nécessaires et c'est notamment vrai
pendant les phases de travaux nous avons
également créé en 2019 une cellule bâtie
scolaire qui a publié un guide à propos
du désamiantage de manière à informer
les usagers et à informer les
collectivités nous sommes conscients
d'un certain nombre de données de santé
publique dont vous faites état et à ce
titre je suis tout à fait favorable à ce
qu'un partage d'informations entre le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale les
collectivités puissent avoir lieu de
manière à avancer sur cette question
importante de santé publique je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre monsieur
Boyard monsieur le ministre comment
pouvez-vous être satisfait de cette
réponse vous parlez mais rien ne change
alors que c'est vous qui avez la
responsabilité de la sécurité des élèves
et des enseignants vous n'avez pas de
chiffres alors organisez des
prélèvements dans toutes les écoles
amiantes et publier ses résultats vous
demandez au mairies de rénover les
écoles mais vous savez très bien qu'elle
n'en ont pas les moyens car c'est à
l'état de créer un fond public national
pour rénover ces écoles mais vous ne
faites rien de tout ça vous préféré
faire l'autruche sacrifier les
générations futures juste pour ne pas
payer alors puisque sur l'amiante la
réponse de l'État c'est l'omerta je me
tourne vers vous chers collègues dans
cet assemblée pas un seul d'entre nous
n'était pas né il y a des enfants
exposés à l'amiante dans chacune de nos
circonscriptions au-delà des clivages
politiques nous avons tous le devoir
d'agir alors je vous le demande madame
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
accepter notre demande de commission
d'enquête pour trouver les solutions et
protéger ses enfants face à l'amiante
c'est le devoir de notre Assemblée
nationale que de ne pas sacrifier les
générations futures
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député je viens de vous
répondre en vous indiquant que c'est une
question importante de santé publique
que nous nous en saisissons ça vaut
mieux que votre numéro habituel de
démagogie on a besoin de travailler
sérieusement sur cette question
nous avons nous sommes en lien avec les
collectivités sur cette question et je
vous prie de croire que nous y
travaillons sérieusement encore une fois
ça vaut mieux que de la démagogie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre
merci la parole est à Madame Aude Luquet
pour le groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur Clément bonne ministre chargé
des transports monsieur le ministre la
loi d'orientation des mobilités de 2019
a précisé un objectif de doublement de
la part modale du transport ferroviaire
dans les grands pôles urbains depuis les
annonces se succèdent celle du président
de la République pour le lancement des
RER métropolitains suivi par un plan de
développement du ferrovia inédit doté de
100 milliards d'euros d'ici 2040
et enfin cette semaine monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé une dotation
de 8,6 milliards d'euros pour les
contrats de plan et ta région pour 2023
2027 les deux tiers de cette enveloppe
iront aux infrastructures ferroviaires
et aux transports publics alors qu'il
faut inciter les Français à utiliser des
transports décarbonés et multiplier les
mobilités propres il est indispensable
que tous les territoires bénéficient
d'un réseau de transport performants et
adapté à notre temps ce réseau doit
s'inscrire dans un projet de territoire
consensuel et respectueux des
collectivités des usagers et des
riverains prenant en compte les
contraintes environnementales aussi
Monsieur le Ministre les projets pensés
presque au siècle dernier sont-ils
encore pertinents en Île-de-France par
exemple et on est ainsi du Tzen conçu il
y a 15 ans pour lequel une étude
d'impact environnementale sur une
nécessaire je parle de ma
circonscription mais le sujet est bien
présent dans nos territoires vos
annonces sur le lion Turin la semaine
passée n'attendent plus qu'une réponse
de la région aura
dans cette même région il a aussi le
sujet de Clermont Paris nécessaire au
désenclavant de certaines communes ou
agglomérations à l'heure où les
négociations l'État et la région vont
débuter pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre
nous dire quelle est l'évolution des
moyens consacrés au sein des contrats en
région les modalités de mise en œuvre
des financements afin que ainsi que leur
calendrier leur articulation avec
l'enveloppe des 100 milliards annoncés
enfin comment comptez-vous intégrer
pleinement les critères environnementaux
dans ces projets en créant une clause de
revoyure et réévaluer ainsi les projets
anciens qui ne seraient plus adaptés je
vous en remercie je vous remercie ma
chère collègue la parole est à monsieur
Clément bonne ministre délégué chargé
des transports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
au Luquet vous soulignez l'importance de
notre investissement dans le domaine des
transports qui est à la fois un enjeu
essentiel pour la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens pour beaucoup de territoires
que vous avez cités dans votre
circonscription et bien au-delà et qui
est un enjeu central de la décarbonation
puisque nous le savons les transports
représentent 30 % de nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre c'est dans cet
esprit que la première ministre dans le
prolongement de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités annoncé un investissement
exceptionnel dans le transport le plan
l'avenir pour les transports au mois de
février dernier il y a quelques semaines
à peine et nous sommes en train de
décliner ces annonces portées par la
première ministre il y a quelques
semaines nous avons commencé très
concrètement à une concertation engagée
une concertation pardon avec les régions
la semaine dernière j'ai annoncé en
effet que les contrats de plan état
région qui manifestent ce partenariat
cet investissement partagé à l'être très
significativement augmentée puisque
c'est une augmentation de 50% des
montants annuels que nous consacrons à
cet investissement assez contrats que
l'État est prêt à porter 8,6 milliards
d'euros derrière des grands chiffres il
y a des choix très notamment une
priorité donnée aux ferroviaires aux
transports publics au RER métropolitain
annoncé par le président de la
République et je veux saluer d'ailleurs
la proposition de loi portée par le
président Voulzy qui sera dans quelques
jours examiné dans cette hémicycle et
qui j'espère sera voté pour donner
au-delà des moyens budgétaires les
outils à nos métropoles à nos régions
pour porter cet effort d'investissement
nous devons évidemment au-delà des
contrats continuer un investissement qui
a été porté depuis quelques années dans
les trains du territoire par exemple je
pense au Paris Clermont qui fait l'objet
d'un programme d'investissement
exceptionnel si je prends là aussi un
simple chiffre c'est 5 milliards d'euros
au-delà des 8 milliards et demi que j'ai
évoqués que l'État est en train
d'investir dans le train d'équilibre du
territoire sur Paris clairement sur
Paris Limoges sur Paris Le Havre sur
beaucoup d'autres sur Bordeaux Marseille
j'étais à Bordeaux vendredi où j'ai
annoncé aussi un effort de
renouvellement le tout le parc de rame
vous le voyez l'État est au rendez-vous
nous attendons maintenant des réponses
des régions vous l'avez évoqué notamment
pour Lyon de Turin nous reverrons un
certain nombre d'autres projets car qui
dit priorité au ferroviaire dit aussi
une plus grande sélectivité sur les
projets routiers nous l'assumons mais
c'est un investissement inédit massif
cohérent dans la durée que nous portons
pour nos territoires partout en France
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Kevin mon vieux
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
connaissez-vous le point commun entre
vous et l'Union européenne votre total
incompétence qui engrais aujourd'hui la
banque et la finance sur le dos des
contribuables
414% c'est la hausse en 2022 du coup de
la dette indexée sur l'inflation dont
vous êtes responsable avec la gauche
qu'il a créé et LR qui l'a perpétuer
pendant des décennies 14 milliards
d'euros encore cette année sont pour le
moment prévu rien qu'en intérêt
300% vous me direz les sommes sont
grosses c'est la hausse du coup estimée
pour le plan de relance européen avec 42
milliards d'euros d'intérêt prévu au
lieu de 15 de 15 milliards seulement par
contre d'un don de la farce dans cette
histoire la France qui n'aperçu que 37
milliards sur les 40 prévus dans ce plan
de relance monsieur le ministre la dette
n'est pas un bon vin elle n'est pas
meilleure parce qu'elle est plus cher
alors on apprend que les 15 milliards
d'euros initialement prévus pour huit
ans seront épuisés dès cet été et que
pour couvrir l'année prochaine
uniquement l'année prochaine Bruxelles
recommande déjà aux états de doubler
l'enveloppe prévu pour 2024 en la
passant de 2 à 4 milliards d'euros une
paille enfin Valérie Haier l'une de vos
députés européens indique déjà qu'il va
falloir créer de nouvelles ressources
propres et qui les jeux cite hors de
question de baisser les dépenses du
budget européen alors Monsieur le
Ministre quelle taxe allez vous créer
pour financer ces charges de dette qui
explosent puisque lieu ne fera pas
d'efforts et quand allez-vous vous
attaquer à notre dette qui nous coûte
aujourd'hui plus cher que le budget de
notre défense
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre délégué
chargé des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Kevin mauvieux je vous avoue que j'étais
assez surpris en entendant votre
question puisque vous entendre nous
donner des leçons de responsabilité
budgétaire alors que dans les débats
budgétaires que nous avons eu l'occasion
d'avoir depuis un an vous n'avez jamais
été capable de proposer une piste
d'économie sérieuse en revanche pour
proposer systématiquement des dépenses
supplémentaires je vous avoue que c'est
un peu difficile d'entendre des leçons
venant de votre part sur ce sujet là
mais nous aurons d'autres débats sur le
sujet prochainement pour ce qui est de
la trajectoire et du désendettement nous
avons présenté avec Bruno Le Maire il y
a quelques semaines un nouveau programme
de stabilité pour les 5 années à venir
plus ambitieux encore que le précédent
qui accélère d'un an le désendettement
de la France qui prévoit un retour sous
les 3% à 2,7% de déficit en 2027 et une
diminution de quatre points de notre
charge de dette rapportée au PIB par
rapport aux précédents programmes de une
fois qu'on a dit ça il va nous falloir
réaliser un certain nombre d'économies
et je constate qu'à chaque fois que nous
proposons des économies une maîtrise de
la dépense publique vous n'êtes jamais
au rendez-vous pour nous accompagner en
revanche vous proposez systématiquement
des dépenses supplémentaires et je vais
vous dire ce qui pose un problème c'est
que ça va à l'encontre du discours que
vous portez que vous êtes ce que vous
affirmez porter sur la souveraineté et
l'indépendance de notre pays vous voulez
condamner notre pays à rester
durablement endetté donc durablement
soumis au marché financier et à la dette
nous assumons d'agir pour l'indépendance
et la souveraineté de notre pays
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
mauve
merci Madame écoutez la modestie
décidément de vous étouffe pas et
pourtant vous devriez en prendre un
petit peu les cadeaux que vous faites
aux banques volontairement ou par
incompétence permettrait de financer
plusieurs fois la baisse de TVA que nous
proposons avec Marine Le Pen et une
hausse des salaires par une diminution
des charges les cadeaux que vous faites
aux banques permettrait de financer un
plan d'envergure pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux bref les cadeaux que
vous faites aux banques a lieu qui nous
prend d'ailleurs plus qu'elles ne nous
donne devrait plutôt profiter aux
Français avec Marine Le Pen nous leur
rendrons leur argent
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député quel cadeau nous
faisons à l'Union européenne vous
critiquez en permanence la contribution
de la France à l'Union européenne parce
que ce qui vous pose un problème c'est
l'adhésion de la France à l'Union
européenne vous vous cachez derrière des
questions budgétaires mais la réalité
c'est que vous voulez c'est la sortie de
la France de l'Union européenne et vous
prétendez que ça serait une mesure
d'économie ce serait la ruine de notre
pays c'est ça qui arriverait si vous
étiez responsabilités
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre
ce 13 juin la question que je vous pose
n'est pas la mienne
pour la première fois des citoyens de ma
circonscription se sont réunis pour
poser au gouvernement une question
citoyenne
ces citoyens qui sont ici
dont je ne suis aujourd'hui que la
porte-parole
ont retenu plusieurs thèmes les déserts
médicaux la vie chère et le manque
d'enseignants mais c'est la question de
la démocratie de leur défiance qu'ils
ont décidé d'exprimer ici
ils disent tous continuer à s'intéresser
à la politique mais que pour eux rien
n'a changé avec le grand débat les
conventions citoyennes et les promesses
d'une démocratie plus représentative
au contraire dit-il nous assistons à
l'utilisation en rafale des articles
49-3-471 et dernièrement l'article 40
or la démocratie ne se limite pas à des
procédures constitutionnelles ce qui la
caractérise c'est la délibération et la
discussion publique ou s'échangent les
arguments contradictoires ces citoyens
considèrent qu'ils ne pèsent plus sur le
cours des choses et que nous les députés
leur représentants sommes ligotées et
notre mandat vidé de sens
alors
c'est pour vous aussi
madame la Première ministre 9 d'entre
eux sont ici présents pour vous alerter
sur le fossé qui se creuse avec les
gouvernants il vous demande si vous en
avez conscience et pour que la vie
politique renoue avec le tous ensemble
quelle mesure concrètes et immédiate
proposez-vous
je précise qu'il vous écoute alors ne
les décevez pas merci beaucoup ma chère
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement merci merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame Cécile Hunter je salue
évidemment les neuf citoyens dont vous
faites la porte-voix et vous félicite à
titre personnel pour cette initiative
fondamentale bienvenue effectivement
tous les citoyens qui sont en tribunes
ce jour comme chaque semaine et qui
écoutent les débats parfois un peu
interloqués d'ailleurs par le bruit qui
peut régner lors de certaines
interventions et qui en général se font
assez vite une idée de qui dans cette
hémicycle constitue les pompiers et qui
sont les pyromanes madame la députée
vous le dites nous traversons une crise
de confiance dans le politique une crise
de confiance qui n'est pas d'ailleurs
que dans le politique elle concerne
aussi les médias qu'on appelle désormais
les médias traditionnels comme pour
mieux les séparer de ce qui serait des
médias non traditionnels et qu'on voit
sur les réseaux sociaux une crise de la
confiance scientifique nous l'avons vu
dans le covid madame la députée une
crise de confiance évidemment politique
mais qui je dirais dépasse tous les
clivages et vous et moi avant siéger sur
le même banc madame la députée il y a
quelques années cela et faisions le même
constat ça rend modeste mais ça rend
surtout notion de l'urgence qu'il y a à
retisser du lien lorsqu'on veut servir
le public et l'intérêt général c'est qui
le cas de tous les parlementaires ici
réunis vous êtes ici pour servir
l'intérêt général et pas votre intérêt
personnel au-delà des clivages partisans
au-delà des clivages politiques et vous
savez au combien vos missions sont
difficiles à l'Assemblée nationale comme
dans vos circonscriptions comment
repenser les mécanismes démocratiques
nous essayons madame la député peut-être
pas avec tous les succès que vous
espérez mais nous essayons la convention
citoyenne sur la fin de vie a été un
modèle du genre les conseils nationaux
de la refondation qui dans tous les
territoires de France animent des
milliers d'établissements scolaires
anime des centaines de communautés
soignantes pour repenser l'école et la
santé de demain le grand débat national
lors du mandat précédent montrent que
nous sommes en train de chercher non pas
le martingale madame la députée mais le
moyen de dire à tous les français quel
que soit leurs idées vous comptez vous
êtes utile et nous avons besoin du lien
qui nous unit à vous merci je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie pour cette réponse
monsieur le ministre simplement vous
dire que le chemin est difficile et que
nous aurons besoin d'être tous ensemble
pour que le débat citoyen vivent encore
Merci beaucoup ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Véronique Riotton
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur et
des Outre-mer monsieur le ministre nous
sommes tous encore choqués par le drame
qui s'est déroulé à Annecy il y a
quelques jours drame qui a bouleversé la
France et le monde
toutes nos pensées cet après-midi se
tourne vers les victimes et leurs
proches
ce drame a eu lieu
pour autant je voudrais saluer ici la
formidable chaîne de solidarité de
coopération dans la gestion de ce drame
et de ses conséquences qui ont pu être
contenus les premiers qui sont
intervenus sont les promeneurs les
lycéens et les acteurs du tourisme qui
étaient sur place et qui ont agi de
façon courageuse soit en appelant les
secours
en faisant des traductions en langue
étrangères en faisant un cordon
sanitaire pour éviter que les plus
petits ne soient pas exposés à ces
scènes si terribles dans un temps record
les professionnels sont intervenus force
de police pompiers puis les soignants et
toute la chaîne de ce cours bien sûr ils
sont formés pour intervenir et le
formidable dispositif mis en place a
permis de limiter les victimes et les
blessures pour autant on n'est jamais
préparé à une telle horreur et leur
émotion ressentie juste après témoigne
de la fragilité de notre humanité le
temps sera long pour refermer ses plaies
et il nous faudra prendre soin de
Monsieur le Ministre ce que je voudrais
dire ici cet après-midi c'est que toutes
les décisions prises l'ont fait et ont
permis de sauver ses enfants ses adultes
et de ne faire aucune nouvelle victime
monsieur le ministre pour ces héros du
quotidien ou professionnel averti je
souhaite que la nation leur exprime sa
reconnaissance et Itude comment selon
vous pouvons-nous les honorer de la
manière la plus juste la plus
républicaine telle qu'il le mérite merci
beaucoup ma chère collègue la parole est
à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
merci merci Madame Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés pardon
madame la députés Véronique Riotton vous
avez raison c'est le service public et
les femmes et les hommes qui le
composent quel que soit leur mission qui
ont permis de sauver ses enfants et ses
victimes et d'éviter d'en faire
davantage je voudrais avoir une pensée
évidemment pour Monsieur le Préfet et
pour ces équipes qui en quelques
instants non seulement à commander les
opérations de secours et de sécurité
mais aussi est intervenu pour évidemment
organiser la mise en sécurité vous
parliez des lycéens qui étaient à
proximité du drame mais aussi des écoles
puisque lorsqu'il arrive une abomination
comme celle d'Annecy la première
question que se pose après fait le
ministère de l'intérieur c'est
évidemment il y a dit d'autres personnes
dans d'autres territoires de la ville
qui peuvent passer à l'acte et
malheureusement la panique bien légitime
évidemment se fait démonstration et il
faut que les services de l'État assurent
et Monsieur préfet a su rassurer tout
dans ces opérations de secours et de
sécurité vous dire aussi que
l'organisation du ministère de
l'Intérieur s'il doit toujours être
amélioré bien évidemment à montrer et
s'en est la responsabilité des femmes et
des hommes qui composent ce ministère
bien sûr son efficacité je rappelle
comment de 3 minutes un équipage de
police est arrivé pour interpeller cette
personne puis une équipe de moto qui ont
pu avant qu'ils puissent continuer ça
marche terrible interpeller cette cette
personne je voudrais avoir une pensée
particulière pour ses policiers qui ont
risqué leur vie dont l'un d'entre eux
vous le savez à utiliser son arme de
service et qui l'ont fait dans des
conditions à la connaissance ministère
de l'intérieur d'un grand
professionnalisme ils étaient d'ailleurs
tous les deux formateurs de tir et tous
les deux majeurs de la police nationale
j'ai proposé au Président de la
République des décorations soient
imaginées pour les prochaines promotions
pour l'ensemble des personnes qui ont
contribué à sauver évidemment ces
personnes et quand l'enquête sera
terminée nous tirons évidemment un bilan
du service étranger jusqu'aux opérations
de secours pour améliorer une nouvelle
fois pour montrer en exemple ce qui
s'est passé ainsi qui malgré une noble a
permis de sauver des vies merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Christine Arrighi
pour le groupe écologiste merci Madame
la
merci madame la Présidente nous
apprenions il y a quelques jours que
l'article pourrait être privé de
banquise dès 2030 soit 10 ans 10 ans
plutôt que les pires projections du GIEC
l'un des piliers de notre climat vient
de tomber de manière irréversible la
disparition de la glace va augmenter les
événements météorologiques extrêmes
partout dans le monde je dis bien
partout dans le monde et générera un
chaos climatique la fonte va entraîner
celle du pergélisol qui émettra des gaz
à effet de serre et parfois de
conséquences la calotte glaciaire du
Groenland qui va se perdre les
scientifiques parlent d'une élévation du
niveau des mers de 6 à 7 mètres
entraînant des déplacements des
populations massives ce sont les
scientifiques qui parlent
188 de ces scientifiques dont Eddy
Sevestre qui est une éminente glatzlogue
française appelle récemment dans une
tribune à stopper le projet eacop en
Ouganda et Tanzanie le projet de plus
long et au duc chauffé du monde et tous
les autres nouveaux projets fossil porté
par Total énergie ce projet à Coop se
sont 379 millions de tonnes de CO2
supplémentaires dans l'atmosphère qui
viennent se rajouter à tous ceux déjà
produits mais aussi des populations
expropriées sans compensation adéquate
les arrestations arbitraires d'opposants
des forages au cœur d'un plat parc
naturel un risque de contamination d'un
lac donc 40 millions de personnes
dépendent et des récifs coralliens en
grande âgées le sommet pour un nouveau
pacte financier mondial organisé à Paris
les 12 et 23 juin est une occasion
unique pour proposer des alternatives il
faut proposer d'inclure dans ce nouveau
pacte financier mondial des financements
au pays qui comme l'Ouganda et la
Tanzanie souhaitent se développer et
pourrait ainsi le faire sans exploiter
leurs ressources fossiles dans le cas
contraire nous emperrons toutes et tous
les conséquences eux les premiers et
quand je dis payer c'est bien dans tous
les sens du terme car comme l'exprimer
récemment les assureurs en commission
des finances en répondant à ma question
sur la couverture du risque le système
assurancial mondial est construit pour
couvrir des risques conjoncturels et pas
structurels
la parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
haché ministre de l'énergie
la transition énergétique excusez-moi
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
à Rigi merci madame la députée à Rigi
effectivement de saluer l'initiative du
Président de la République d'organiser
cette réunion sur ce sommet de Paris
pour avancer sur un nouveau pacte
financier mondial qui nous permettra de
revoir les modalités de financement
climatique et d'ouvrir une nouvelle voie
pour les pays vulnérables qui
aujourd'hui ne peuvent accompagner leur
développement à la vitesse qu'ils
souhaitent en combinant développement et
solutions du futur quand je dis solution
du futur c'est un développement qui est
basé sur les énergies renouvelables qui
est basée sur une énergie décarbonée ce
que nous faisons aujourd'hui au travers
de projet je pense au jetpi ces projets
en Afrique du Sud au Vietnam par exemple
qui permettent d'accompagner en
investissant massivement dans la
décarbonation de ces économies la sortie
du charbon pour l'Afrique du Sud la
sortie des énergies fossiles pour le
Vietnam et en accompagnant des projets
qui soient créateurs de richesse et
créateurs d'emploi pour pour ces pays il
s'agit au fond d'inventer un nouveau
modèle de développement durable dans ces
pays pour qu'ils évitent de passer par
la case développant durable fondé sur
les énergies fossiles alors quel est
l'objectif du président de la République
d'abord réformer les finances
multilatérales parce que vous avez
souligné il y a des difficultés d'accès
aux financement multilatéral il y a
également concentré les subventions les
les soutiens climatiques publiques et
vous savez que la France prend toute sa
part avec 6 milliards d'euros pour faire
émerger des nouveaux projets des projets
qui sont rationnels d'un point de vue
économique rationnel d'un point de vue
climatique rationnel d'un point de vue
social des risques ces projets faire en
sorte qu'ils aient vraiment lieu et
faire en sorte ensuite que les
financements privés puissent se diriger
vers ces pays ce sont les objectifs que
nous poursuivons avec le sommet de Paris
il fixera une feuille de route que nous
aurons à mettre en oeuvre derrière avec
la cop28 et les différents membres
événements climatiques de cette année
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien
Pradier pour le groupe les républicains
vaut la vie d'une adolescente de 15 ans
humilié violet tabassé poignardé 15 fois
le visage aspergé des sens et brûlez
vive brûler vive que vaut dans notre
République le martyre de Shaina
l'assassin de la jeune Shayna dont le
corps a été retrouvé calciné au fond
d'un cabanon de Creil vient d'être jugé
son bourreau a écopé de 18 ans de
réclusion 30 ans avaient été requis il
fera tout au plus 12 ans derrière les
barreaux voilà ce que vaut l'assassinat
de Shayna douce petites années de
réclusion l'excuse de minorité aura
sauvé le bourreau pas Shaina comment
donner l'excuse de minorité à des actes
dont l'horreur et la préméditation non
plus rien à voir avec ceux de mineur le
soir du crime l’auteur raconte fièrement
à ses amis qu'il a fumé Shaina au procès
il parle d'elle comme d'une elle a
été brûlée vive enceinte six ans
d'attente pour le premier procès un
violeur qui retrouve librement sa
victime et la tabasse deux ans avant
l'assassinat Shaina faisait partie des
146 féminicides de 2019 nous sommes à 55
depuis le début de l'année
une juridiction spécialisée contre les
violences faites aux femmes avaient été
promises par Emmanuel Macron elle a été
enterrée notre justice ne sait plus
prononcer la perpétuité réelle elle
aménage elle excuse vous êtes devenu le
gouvernement d'une justice impuissante
et injuste les règles doivent changer si
nous oublions Shaina nous serons vous
serez d'une lâcheté un pardonnable
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre délégué
chargé du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Aurélien Pradier d'abord j'excuse de
garder sceau qui est actuellement retenu
au Sénat
monsieur pour le vote d'une loi
important sur la justice monsieur le
député je partage votre peine et votre
colère face au drame inhumain qui a
touché la jeune China et sa famille j'ai
eu l'occasion moi-même de rencontrer son
frère Yassine et j'ai un immense respect
pour le courage du combat qu'il mène
ainsi que pour ses parents
l'assassin a perdu une part de son
humanité en commettant cet acte et a
tenter d'affaiblir notre humanité
collective mais nous sommes forts et la
République est forte elle est là pour
assurer la protection des victimes pour
rendre le jugement monsieur le député ce
qui me gêne dans votre interpellation
c'est qu'il existe dans notre pays un
principe important fondamental et vous
le connaissez qui s'appelle la
séparation des pouvoirs comme
représentant de l'exécutif et sans avoir
de leçons à vous donner comme
représentant du législateur messieurs
les député sur cette très courte
peut-être si vous pouviez
comme représentant du législateur quel
que soit ce que peut vous inspirer la
décision qui a été rendue elle a été
rendue dans une cour d'assise par un
jury populaire représentant la
population par un jury populaire
monsieur le député et à l'heure à
laquelle je vous parle nous sommes
encore dans le délai qui court qui
permet à la famille si elle le souhaite
de faire appel donc cette affaire n'est
pas complètement jugée encore monsieur
le député vous interrogez le
Gouvernement sur ce que nous avons fait
vous parlez notamment des juridictions
spécialisées je vous confirme qu'il y
aura des pôles spécialisés pour venir en
aide aux victimes et pour juger tout ce
qui est violence et féministe qui sont
en train de se mettre en place monsieur
le député personne ne dit que nous
sommes allés au bout de la démarche mais
il y a eu pas moins de quatre lois
depuis 2017 c'est la grande cause de
deux quinquennat successifs nous avons
mis en place les bracelets électroniques
nous avons mis en place les téléphones
grands danger nous avons 1000 une en
place une ligne d'écoute 24 nous avons
multiplié par deux le nombre de
condamnations au pénal pour les auteurs
de violence nous développons non pas un
ou cinq mais des dizaines de centres qui
viennent en aide aux femmes victimes de
viol ences quel que soit la sorte de ces
violences ce combat monsieur le député
il n'est pas idéologique qui ne porte
pas une couleur politique il doit nous
unir tous dans cette hémicycle merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre monsieur
Pradier
monsieur le ministre dans le parcours de
Shaina il y a des failles ne pas les
voir c'est irresponsable des failles de
la justice un premier auteur de viol
collectif relâché interdit d'approcher
Creil qui finit par y être autorisé et
qui tabasse la petite China dans le
parcours de Shaina il y a beaucoup de
nos faiblesses ne pas les voir c'est là
la véritable acheter nous avons le
pouvoir d'agir vous devriez l'avoir
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane peu pour le groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale plus que dans n'importe quel
autre pays de l'OCDE le système éducatif
français
reproduit les inégalités sociales au
lieu de les corriger pire notre système
les aggrave c'est pourquoi vos
déclarations pour favoriser la mixité
scolaire avec suscité un vif intérêt
dans le pays oui l'assignation et
l'enfermement des enfants de notre pays
à leur situation sociale d'origine sont
indignes de la France l'excellence
éducative se concentre désormais dans
les cœurs gentrifiés des métropoles et
les territoires les plus bourgeois comme
en témoignent les disparités accablantes
des indices de position sociale entre
les établissements statistiques que
l'État a trop longtemps tenu secrète il
s'agit là d'un véritable séparatisme qui
mine les fondements de notre République
car nous en sommes convaincus
pays qui laissent les inégalités se
creuser est un pays qui régresse
monsieur le ministre nous ne voulons pas
ouvrir ouvrir une nouvelle guerre
scolaire mais nous ne supportons plus la
guerre sociale dans son victime les
élèves issus des milieux populaires j'ai
donc deux questions premièrement
s'agissant de s'agissant de
l'enseignement privé sous contrat quelle
suite entendez-vous donner aux rapports
de la Cour des comptes qui s'émeut de
l'absence de contrôle et de contrepartie
en termes de mixité sociale sachant que
73% de leur financement provient de
l'État et des collectivités deuxièmement
alors que le département le plus riche
de France hexagonale et mitoyens du
département le plus pauvre quelle suite
allez-vous donner à la proposition que
vous avez vous-même jugé décoiffante de
réunir dans une même académie Paris et
la Seine-Saint-Denis
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur papenzahi ministre
de la jeunesse et de l'éducation
nationale merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le députés Stéphane vous avez
raison favoriser la mixité sociale et
scolaire c'est améliorer le système
scolaire en général c'est amélioré le
climat scolaire le climat social c'est
même d'ailleurs aussi favoriser les
principes de laïcité nous devons donc
avancer et c'est pour cela que nous
avons
établi à la fois un protocole d'accord
avec le secrétariat général de
l'enseignement catholique je vais y
revenir mais également avec des conseils
départementaux puisque les collectivités
ont une responsabilité imminente
imminente en particulier en matière de
sectorisation tout dépend des
territoires il y a des territoires dans
lesquels il faut agir avec un certain
nombre de leviers d'autres avec d'autres
leviers on a fixé un objectif c'est une
amélioration de 20% de la mixité sociale
avec en laissant au recteur le soin
d'agir sur un certain nombre de leviers
et de passer contrat avec les présidents
du Conseil départementaux en ce qui
concerne l'enseignement privé ce contrat
pour la première fois depuis 30 ans un
protocole a été signé par lequel
l'enseignement privé sous contrat prend
un certain nombre d'engagements
établis des relations pérennes avec les
autorités académiques et puis nous nous
avons également des moyens en quelque
sorte d'incitation en attribuant des
postes à des établissements privés sous
contrat qui feront des efforts par
exemple en ouvrant une classe SEGPA où
en ouvrant une classe Ulysse plutôt qu'à
d'autres établissements du côté de la
scène Saint-Denis la proposition qui a
été faite par le président du conseil
départemental à mon sens ne va pas
améliorer la situation nous avons
d'ailleurs fait des simulations sur 10
ans parce que ça prendrait 10 ans et
donc en l'espèce nous préférons nous
concentrer sur un tiers des collèges les
collèges les plus en difficulté du
département à peu près 40 sur lesquels
nous allons investir massivement le
Conseil départemental et l'éducation
nationale merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
la parole est à Madame Sophie errande
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la Présidente mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
Véran porte-parole du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre le site
expérimental des maraîchers nantais et
le cœur de la transition la filière vers
une culture plus durable et pourtant des
personnes qui se disent défenseurs de la
planète ou un néanti une partie de ce
travail essentiel ce weekend c'est aussi
désolant qui n'acceptable je tiens à mon
nom et en y associons mon collègue
yannikori et mes collègues de la
majorité présidentielle du département a
apporté tout notre soutien au maraîcher
victime de ses actes insupportables ces
actions s'inscrivent dans une mouvance
ancienne consistant à considérer les
actions directes et violentes comme
nécessaire pour forcer les gouvernements
à agir l'idéologie radicale ne cherche
pas à construire mais seulement des
lieux d'affrontement il compte même et
c'est un comble soutien actif de membres
de notre assemblée en effet quand l'un
de nous affirme dans la presse je cite
il faut faire la différence entre la
violence et la dégradation rien quand un
élu de la République est plus allé
législateur ne sait pas que la
dégradation des biens d'autrui est
illégal je crois qu'il serait bon de
rappeler le sens et l'exigence que
représente le port de l'écharpe
tricolore dans les bâtiments de la
République mais aussi à l'extérieur il
n'est pas plus acceptable qu'une
minorité de la population Bafou l'État
de droit quel qu'on soit le motif une
société où les individus considèrent
qu'ils peuvent faire pression de manière
illégale pour défendre une cause sans
aucune conséquence c'est une société qui
ne garantit plus le vivre ensemble
monsieur le ministre ces actions ne
peuvent rester impunies si nous voulons
garantir l'État de droit et la confiance
dans nos institutions mais question sont
simples quelles réponses est-il possible
d'apporter à nos concitoyens victimes de
ces actions quel dispositif
prévoyez-vous pour les protéger ou en
sommes-nous du démantèlement du
collectif Les soulèvement de la terre
quelle modalités réglementaire pourrait
permettre de démanteler dans la durée ce
type de structure et enfin comment
peut-on garantir l'exemplarité attendu
dans un état de droit des représentants
de notre nation et de ses élus je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est un monsieur
Olivier Véran ministre chargé du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Sophie errante merci pour votre question
d'abord vous dire que le Gouvernement
partage évidemment votre indignation
comme elle partage l'indignation même
logique tout à l'heure qui
m'interrogeait sur le sur le même sujet
un soutien évident à l'ensemble des
agriculteurs qui je pense ont regardé et
BT une serre qui avait été détruite
taguée des plans de salades qui ont été
arrachés du muguet vous m'expliquez
comment on défend la planète en
arrachant des salades et du plan de
muguet vous savez ce que ça veut dire
madame la députée ça veut dire que pour
cette association qui se fait appeler
les soulèvements de la terre l'écologie
n'est qu'un prétexte
et ça rappelle à la représentation
nationale s'il le fallait que
l'obscurantisme est une plaie pour
l'humanité ça ne fait pas avancer ça ne
fait pas progresser ça ne sert pas la
cause écologique ça ne sert pas la cause
agricole
et voir des élus qui s'associent à cela
c'est un mauvais combat mes chers
collègues vous qui parfois regardez avec
mansuétude voir avec envie ces actions
c'est soi-disant activiste de la part de
ces associations c'est un mauvais combat
c'est une mauvaise manière de le mener
ce combat je le redis volontiers ce qui
fait progresser la cause écologique ce
sont les réformes que vous votez
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés et que
nous portons l'échelle européenne à
l'échelle mondiale pour préserver notre
biodiversité des actions qui sont
courageux et qui sont efficaces et ne
nous l'aurons pas ne nous l'aurons pas
si c'est en France que des associations
comme les comme les soulèvements de la
terre viennent le faire c'est parce que
justement la France est un pays qui est
à l'écoute de la cause écologique et qui
agit pour cela si vous avez du courage
ils iraient faire leurs actions dans des
pays où l'écologie ne compte pas et ont
pollu la planète jour après jour
madame la députée pour dissoudre une
association il faut des éléments qui
soient absolument imparable imparable et
donc un dossier un dossier est en cours
d'être monté pour pouvoir être présenté
normalement devant la justice en vue
d'obtenir la dissolution de cette
association comme l'avait expliqué le
ministre de l'Intérieur croyait en la
détermination du gouvernement pour
apporter tous en soutien aux
agriculteurs pour apporter tout son
soutien à l'écologie et pour ne jamais
accepter ce type d'exaction et
soi-disant activisme
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Monsieur Nicolas maizonnet pour le
groupe rassemblement national merci
madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances Bruno Le
Maire novembre 2021 vous déclariez
l'inflation est temporaire août 2022
nous sommes au pic de l'inflation
septembre 2022 le pouvoir d'achat des
Français continuera de progresser
février 2023 il n'y aura pas de mars
rouge monsieur le ministre les archives
de vos promesses et prédictions sont
accablantes tout autant que votre bilan
et pour cause votre action politique se
résume à aller quémander à la grande
distribution quelques efforts à menacer
les industriels qui ne baisseraient pas
leurs prix de diffuser leur nom mais
comme le dit l'adage chien qui aboie ne
mord pas et à multiplier l'échec avec le
retour du fameux chèque alimentaire
promis par Emmanuel Macron depuis 2020
pourtant ce n'est pas faute de vous
avoir mis en garde la politique d'échec
c'est la politique de l'échec les
résultats parlent d'eux-mêmes la hausse
des produits alimentaires a encore
atteint plus de 14% sur un an alors les
Français souffrent 3 millions d'entre
eux ont recours à l'aide d'alimentaire
un Français sur trois vit avec 100 euros
à partir du 10 du mois un Français sur 4
dit avoir des difficultés à nourrir sa
famille c'est la conséquence de votre
obstination à ne pas appliquer les
mesures pérennes que le rassemblement
national vous propose depuis des mois la
suppression de la TVA sur un panier de
100 produits de première nécessité et la
baisse de la TVA de 20 à 5,5 sur
l'ensemble des énergies aujourd'hui nous
savons que ces mesures que vous avez
tentées de disqualifier d'ailleurs par
le mensonge porte leurs fruits au
Portugal ou la TVA a été supprimée sur
les produits alimentaires l'inflation
est à 4% le prix des denrées de base a
baissé le pouvoir d'achat s'est amélioré
quand je me regarde je me désole quand
je me compare je me console mais avec
votre politique monsieur le ministre
c'est l'exact contraire alors ma
question est la suivante
qu'attendez-vous pour faire votre
autocritique et mettre en place ces
mesures pour le bien des Français
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des PME du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme
monsieur le député maisonnée oui
l'inflation alimentaire baisse enfin au
Portugal
et il faut je crois en réjouir parce que
sur ces débats concernant l'inflation
alimentaire il faut être précis
l'inflation au Portugal au plan
alimentaire elle était supérieur à 15 %
sur un an et ce depuis l'été dernier
l'histoire était clairante alors que
chez nous elle l'a franchi ce seuil
qu'en février 2023 à une époque
d'ailleurs si éventuellement je peux
vous répondre c'est la sens c'est
toujours la même limonade on peut jamais
répondre s'il vous plaît un peu de
silence en l'occurrence si le débat vous
intéresse au Portugal en février dernier
elle était à plus de 20%. alors on va
prendre votre votre proposition la
baisse de l'inflation alimentaire est-ce
qu'elle est du OUI ou NON à la baisse de
la TVA prenons deux exemples l'Allemagne
ou l'inflation alimentaire a reculé tout
aussi fortement qu'au Portugal sans
vraiment toucher à la TVA rien n'a été
fait en matière de TVA ça va bien se
passer monsieur Tanguy gardez votre
calme sur l'Espagne c'est un exemple
aussi très enrichissant l'Espagne a
baissé sa TVA et pour le coup depuis
quand c'est un quiz l'inflation
alimentaire baisse depuis la fin du mois
d'avril et quand est-ce que la TVA a été
supprimée au mois de décembre pendant 4
mois l'inflation alimentaire à quoi vont
continuer à augmenter alors oui plutôt
qu'une proposition qui coûterait plus de
plutôt qu'une proposition qui coûterait
plus de 10 milliards d'euros puisque
vous campez sur votre seul proposition
dont nous n'avons toujours aucune
garantie qu'elle servirait la baisse des
prix pour les consommateurs nous
agissons avec les distributeurs avec les
industriels les baisses de prix sont en
cours portant pendant que certains
pérorent notamment sur ses bancs les
industriels sont en train de négocier
les baisses iront entre 5 et 20% dans
les semaines qui viennent il y a
toujours ceux qui causent et ceux qui
font je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole
la parole est à me sauve 20 sentier bon
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de la Jeunesse
éducation nationale
depuis plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
je suis interpellé quasiment toutes les
semaines par les parents d'élèves sont
un problématique du non remplacement des
professeurs absents
cette situation est dramatique elle est
vécue dans beaucoup d'établissements du
département mais comme dans beaucoup
dans d'autres dans notre pays et
aujourd'hui nous avons fait face à une
situation inquiétante et urgente
situation des conséquences dramatiques
il voulait connaissez c'est des élèves
qui se retrouvent soit dans des classes
surchargées soit qui n'ont plus court
que deux jours par semaine jusqu'à la
fin de l'année scolaire soit aussi la
problématique des parents qui sont
obligées de s'absenter de leur travail
pour pouvoir garder les élèves et même
avec des témoignages inquiétants je vous
cite une maman j'ai démissionné à cause
des absences de des absences non
remplacées des enseignants de mes
enfants c'est ingérable pour moi cette
situation est vraiment inquiétante le 26
mai le collectif qui regroupe 18
associations d'enseignants et de parents
d'élèves a obtenu une conférence de
presse à Strasbourg pour alerter sur ce
sujet ils ont mis en place un système de
QR code pour signaler les situations
inquiétantes 87 à l'aide ont été
remontés depuis le mois de février
dans sa feuille de route la première
ministre a annoncé vouloir changer les
choses concernant la question du
professeur absent cette question nous
devons la prendre à bras le corps il en
y va de l'avenir notre système éducatif
mais surtout avant tout de l'avenir de
nos enfants monsieur le ministre ou vu
de ses situations envisagez-vous un
véritable fléchage mystériel de post
dédié remplacement et quels sont vos
plans d'action pour la plan pour la
rentrée prochaine pour assurer les
parents d'élèves et surtout assurer une
scolarité normale à l'ensemble de nos
enfants merci
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur papenza et ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Thibault la question que vous posez est
importante elle soulève celle de la
continuité du service public d'éducation
nous y répondons d'une double manière à
cette question qui est celle des
remplacements non assurés plusieurs
millions d'heures sont perdus chaque
année
c'est un fait incontestable deux
réponses d'abord à partir de la rentrée
la mise en place du pacte avec de
nouvelles missions parmi lesquelles des
remplacements des missions de
remplacement de courte durée de manière
ça se fait déjà d'ailleurs dans un
certain nombre d'établissements de
manière à ce que les trous dans les
emplois du temps disparaissent et au vu
d'ailleurs de l'inscription des
professeurs pour ces nouvelles missions
nous avons nous sommes très confiants
sur le démarrage rapide du pacte à
partir du 1er septembre la deuxième
réponse c'est celle de l'attractivité du
métier en effet à la fin de chaque année
budgétaire nous rendons entre guillemets
plusieurs milliers de postes que nous
n'avons pas pu pour voir par conséquent
la question elle n'est pas forcément
celle d'augmenter des postes que nous
allons rendre à la fin de l'année elle
est celle de pourvoir des postes
notamment dans certaines académies pour
le premier degré et dans certaines
disciplines pour le second degré c'est
pour cela que nous faisons le
gouvernement la première ministre et le
président de la République un effort
budgétaire considérable pour augmenter
la rémunération des enseignants avec des
augmentations qui pour les 15 premières
années iront de 7,8 à 11,3% à quoi
s'ajoute l'émission possible qui
elle-même seront rémunérés nous avons
également à travailler sur les carrières
nous avons également à répondre à une
question sociale qui est celle de la
place que nous nous souhaitons donner à
nos professeurs dans notre pays et je
souhaite que cette place soit
revalorisée une place à la fois
symbolique et sociale merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
monsieur Jean-Yves Bonnie pour le groupe
les républicains merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire la France veut-elle en cours
de ces troupeaux de salaire d'Aubrac de
limousine de charolaise de Blonde
d'Aquitaine veut-elle encore de ces
prairies que ces animaux
pâturent-elles miser sur les éleveurs
brésiliens pour remplir les assiettes de
nos concitoyens quitte à voir ces
paysages se transformer et ces
territoires se vider la question mérite
d'être posée tellement nos éleveurs sont
régulièrement mis aux bancs des accusés
même la Cour des comptes s'en est mêlée
en croire certains nos élevages seraient
devenus de véritables industries
polluantes quel hérésie dans le Cantal
où il y a bien plus dans le Cantal où il
y a bien plus de vaches que d'habitants
nous respirons pourtant bien mieux qu'à
Paris
et oui monsieur le ministre le Cantal et
les départements le moins pollué de
France même avec ses vaches
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui les éleveurs
luttent pour leur suivi survie en 60 ans
la France a perdu 3 millions de vaches
et cette dynamique terrifiante
s'accélère sur les 7 dernières années la
perte s'élève à 1 million dans le même
temps 2000 éleveurs ont quitté leur
activité la conséquence directe est un
pic des importations et la perte de
notre souveraineté alimentaire près de
30% de la viande bovine que nous
consommons est importée de pays dans les
éleveurs n'ont pas façonné nos paysages
non pas contribuer à la l'immersion de
nos villages alors que la France est
réputée dans le monde entier pour son
élevage
pour toutes ces raisons c'est
provocation faite au monde agricole
monsieur le ministre accepteriez-vous de
travailler un plan de relance de la
filière et quels axes en serait quels
actes serait-il
accéderez-vous à la demande de la
profession d'inclure la viande bovine de
ces renégociations internationales
merci vous avez écoulé votre temps la
parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Véran ministre délégué chargé du
renouveau démocratique et porte-parole
du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Jean-Yves Bonny
il y a des réponses qui doivent
commencer par la conclusion je
commençais par la conclusion comme ça
vous serez fixé sur l'intention du
gouvernement vive l'élevage vive
l'agriculture française c'est dit
maintenant je peux dérouler un peu si
vous voulez pour vous dire que on
partage les mois qui a pu être celui des
agriculteurs et des nombreux élus qui
s'en sont relayés suite à un rapport de
la Cour des comptes qui nous semble
mettre un certain nombre de données
quand on parle d'élevage d'ailleurs les
éleveurs et les agriculteurs en ont
marre d'être stigmatisés on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec certaines soi-disant
associations on en parle parfois sur
certains plateaux de télé etc les
agriculteurs ils nous font manger donc
ils nous font vivre et donc on a besoin
d'eux il faut qu'on leur dise qu'on les
aime et je crois que l'épreuve d'amour
ce gouvernement leur en apporte et leur
en apportera encore à l'occasion des
renégociations de traiter européen
internationaux auxquels vous faites
allusion et pourquoi est-ce qu'on les
aime pas seulement parce qu'ils nous
font nourrir mais parce que
l'agriculture c'est bon pour la planète
c'est bon pour l'écologie j'ai quelques
chiffres c'est vrai que j'aime bien les
chiffres un hectare un hectare de
prairies permanente c'est 110 kg de CO2
absorbé chaque année
les prairies stockent 8 millions de
tonnes de CO2 chaque année dans notre
pays et l'élevage produit des engrais
pourquoi vous criez si on est d'accord
c'était pas contre moi ce coup-là
d'accord ah bah alors allez-y n’empêche
ça vous passez au-dessus monsieur le
ministreur de l'opposition de gauche qui
a le droit aussi à écouter la réponse en
silence du ministre pardon madame la
Présidente
il faut que ça s'arrête
l'élevage produit des engrais organiques
qui sont nécessaires à l'agriculture
biologique et enfin l'élevage permet
aussi la lutte contre les incendies on
l'a vu l'été dernier on le verra
malheureusement encore cet été bref vous
l'aurez compris il y a des mots d'amour
mais des preuves d'amour comptez sur le
ministre d'agriculture il est pas là il
est en Suède justement pour un conseil
informel des ministres de l'Agriculture
pour redire aux agriculteurs la
conclusion je la refais maintenant vive
l'élevage et vive l'agriculture
française monsieur le député merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Ludovic Mendes pour le
groupe Renaissance merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre des Transports
Clément bonne
comme vous le savez la région Grand Est
région transfrontalière à part entière à
des attentes particulières fortes sur
les mobilités et notamment dans notre
beau département de la Moselle en effet
chaque jour ce sont plus de 100 000
Français du sillon le Rhin qui partent
travailler au Luxembourg et pour que les
enjeux de mobilité sont au cœur de leur
quotidien pour autant c'est même
milliers de Français se retrouvent soit
en tassés dans un train qui d'ailleurs
sont soit supprimés soit en retard ou
son bloqués pendant des heures sur leur
voiture pour faire 50 km sous
l'autoroute à 31 axe routier
complètement surchargé ces
problématiques démontent que nous vivons
sur un territoire dynamique qui a besoin
de préparer son avenir sereinement en
pérennisant son attractivité pour se
faire le maintien le développement de
l'aéroport Metz Nancy et de la gare
Lorraine TGV qui se trouve à quelques
kilomètres l'un de l'autre au cœur de ma
circonscription sont essentielles tout
comme la liaison ferroviaire Nord-Sud
Lorraine Méditerranée ainsi que le
transport fluvial du Calmès et le plus
grand port s'est rallié de France
une région comme la nôtre au cœur de
l'Europe et qui concentre les échanges
nord-sud et est-ouest a besoin
d'annonces fortes pour son avenir
touristique écologique et économique de
plus ces annonces doivent être en lien
avec l'enjeu mondial du réchauffement
climatique en permettant de favoriser le
transport des carbonés et responsable
ainsi que les plateformes multimodales
vous nous avez annoncé un investissement
de plus de 8 milliards d'euros jusqu'à
la fin du quinquennat soit une
augmentation de plus de 50% par rapport
à la période précédente et quant à la
région Grand Est 650 millions d'euros
seront investis dans le cadre des
contrats de plan état région en plus des
financements attendus par les
collectivités locales le développement
de notre territoire par la mobilité
garantit le développement économique
favorise le lien social et
l'accessibilité aussi la mobilité pour
tous doit répondre aux besoins des
personnes en situation de handicap
monsieur le ministre nous vous
remercions de cet effort considérable
pour vous pouvez vous nous détailler le
plan d'avenir pour les transports et
particulièrement pour la région Grand
Est la Moselle je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidence mesdames et
messieurs députés monsieur le député
Ludovic Mendes votre question me donne
l'occasion de revenir brièvement après
la réponse que je viens de faire sur les
enjeux de ce plan d'avenir pour les
transports son contenu véritablement
inédit en montant d'investissement que
portent l'État et notamment les contrats
de plan est à région que nous avons
engagé sous l'autorité de la première
mise dès la semaine dernière puisqu'on
était signés les mandats de négociation
de ces contrats de plans au préfet de
région pour commencer sans attendre ses
négociations pour l'ensemble du pays je
le redis c'est un effort sans précédent
8,6 milliards d'euros c'est 50% de plus
tout simplement que la génération
précédente de contrat de plan c'est pour
le ferroviaire et pour les transports
publics 70% de l'enveloppe nous faisons
un choix très clair d'investissement
dans les transports publics dans les
transports des carbonés qui n'ont jamais
été porté à cette ampleur et à ce niveau
nous faisons aussi un choix sur ces
enveloppes là de doubler les montants
absolus que nous consacrons au
ferroviaire et les transports publics je
crois que l'engagement pour la région
Grand Est comme pour toutes les régions
de France et très clair très fort et
aujourd'hui selon et trébuchant il ne
peut plus y avoir de doute sur
l'engagement déclinaison de ce plan de
100 milliards d'euros annoncé en février
par la première ministre pour la région
Grand Est vous connaissez mon
attachement pas seulement à votre beau
département de la Moselle aux enjeux de
transport et de mobilité j'étais il y a
encore peu de temps nous avons des
projets à discuter avec la région je ne
préjuguerai pas de l'issue de cette
négociation je crois pouvoir dire que le
président de Région Franck Leroy est
ouvert à cette discussion satisfait de
l'engagement de l'État et croit pouvoir
le dire dès les prochaines semaines je
l'espère je le souhaite j'y suis engagé
avec lui nous pourrons conclure ce
contrat de plan état région il portera
des engagements majeurs notamment sur le
Sillon Lorrain pour développer
évidemment
décongestionner nos actions routiers
mais développer aussi le transport
ferroviaire et transports publics je
pense au projet de RER métropolitain qui
sera un des actes structurant de ce plan
en France et dans la région Grand Est
nous aurons des discussions apportées
sur les liaisons en transfrontalière de
manière générale aussi et je suis engagé
pour que ensemble nous trouvions des
solutions sur d'autres projets très
précis je pense notamment à la région à
la liaison pardon Nancy Lyon qui est
cher à votre cœur et à beaucoup d'autres
députés je sais le président Valence et
d'autres parlementaires j'y suis engagé
et nous trouvons l’ici la fin de l'année
des solutions pour rétablir cette
liaison essentielle merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur Mendes
merci Monsieur bus pour ces réponses et
le milieu économique vous attend
d'ailleurs avec impact Lorraine vous
avez écrit nous avons répondu vous ne
répondez aujourd'hui et nous vous
remercions leur nom aussi merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien de
l'augu pour le groupe la France
insoumise
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre ce matin une tribune inédite
portée par le collectif des familles de
victimes et une cinquantaine
d'associations marseillaises a été
publiée dans Mediapart soutenu par plus
de 200 parlementaires et une dizaine de
mères elle appelle l'État à ses
obligations et exiger la mise en place
d'une réponse politique globale elle
devra traiter aussi bien des
conséquences de ces violences que des
causes qui alimentent que des causes qui
les alimentent les semaines et les mois
passent et les fusillades et les
assassinats se multiplient à Marseille
et partout en France ces meurtres sont
l'arbre qui cachent une forêt de
conséquences beaucoup plus systémique
auxquels ni vous ni votre gouvernement
ne semble vouloir s'attaquer la misère
et la précarité des habitants de nos
quartiers l'accès aux droits de plus en
plus difficile car les services publics
ferment ce sont des générations entières
qui naissent et qui grandissent à
l'écart de l'égalité républicaine
à l'abandon généralisée s'ajoutent un
discours raciste plein de mépris et de
haine à l'Assemblée nationale on ne
parle jamais des miens ni de leur avenir
sauf pour les salir à travers des
discours qui visent à les rendre
coupables à rendre coupable celles et
ceux qui sont en fait les principales
victimes de cette situation dans nos
quartiers
nos quartiers ne refuse pas la
République au contraire il apporte au
chaque jour dans les actions de Kamel
gué Marie d'une Henriette Saïd de nyans
Sorel d'un solide mbae d'unanisa sherfa
et toutes ces hommes et ses femmes qui
se substituent à un état
depuis trop longtemps démissionnaire
monsieur Darmanin
j'espère que l'unification des mesures
que vous avez mises en place vous amène
aujourd'hui un peu plus d'humilité
rendez aux habitants thé aux habitants
de nos quartiers la justice et la paix
monsieur Darmanin vous qui n'avez eu
aucun mot pour ses morts
qu'attendez-vous pour établir l'égalité
républicaine merci merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
j'ai pas regardé merci madame la
Présidente de Monsieur député monsieur
le député Sébastien de l'augu on peut se
rejoindre sur beaucoup de vos constats
vous êtes élus des quartiers populaires
vous êtes issus du quartier populaire je
suis élu du quartier populaire et je
suis issu du quartier populaire et vous
avez
et vous avez parfaitement raison à la
base de tout il y a l'égalité
républicaine l'accès au logement l'accès
à l'école l'accès à la santé l'accès à
l'éducation et je ne peux que vous
rejoindre dans ce combat républicain qui
parfois explique des dérives qui vient
sur ne sont pas excusables mais qui
justifie l'action beaucoup plus
puissante que peut faire la République
et la France pour sauver ses enfants ses
enfants de la République souvent les
plus pauvres ne concitoyens alors il y a
l'action du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
lui traite vous l'avez dit les
conséquences à lutte contre la drogue et
vous savez bien qu'à Marseille il y a
beaucoup de drogues il y a beaucoup
d'activités des services de police il y
a sur les fusillades qui dessine
évidemment des familles entières vous le
savez deux clans qui s'affrontent en ce
moment même à Marseille sur lequel la
police judiciaire travaille et puis il y
a tout ce qu'on fait en amont et ce qui
a annoncé président de la République qui
se rendra très bientôt à Marseille le
plan Marseille en grand vous aurez sans
doute une discussion avec lui à ce
moment-là des efforts sans précédent que
toutes les villes de France aimeraient
bien avoir et qu'à Marseille et qui a
besoin évidemment Marseille pour sauver
les enfants évidemment de cet avenir moi
je vais vous remercier Monsieur le
Député parce que nous avons un échange
et je vous encouragé voir les services
de police et vous l'avez fait vous avez
rencontré la préfète de police vous avez
rencontré les les CRS de rencontrer les
policiers de la BAC je pense que vous
avez eu un échange et vous avez vu la
difficulté de leur métier je veux vous
dire que vous m'avez demandé de
rencontrer les collectifs je le ferai
quand je reviendrai que le Président de
la République à Marseille lorsque vous
m'inviterez dans cette très jolie ville
et je veux dire que il n'y a pas ici ou
là de gens qui ont à mon avis une si
grande différence après session oui les
enfants des quartiers populaires sont
avant tout ce qu'il faut protéger et pas
simplement par l'intervention de la
police
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Bruno Milliane
pour le groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre du travail et du
plein emploi et de l'insertion monsieur
le ministre promulgué depuis bientôt
deux mois la réforme des retraites et
pleinement engagée par les services de
l'État avec la sortie des premiers
décrets début juin au-delà de la mesure
dash à réforme permettra de remettre
plus de justice sociale dans notre
régime de retraite en revalorisant les
plus petites retraites en réduisant le
nombre d'années de cotisations pour les
carrières longues nous l'avons vu depuis
6 mois et encore hier le débat public
sur cette réforme a trop souvent été
polluée par des fausses informations et
des raccourcis qui ont pu induire
certains de nos concitoyens en erreur
tant et si bien qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
en demande d'une information claire et
fiable sur le sujet comme le montre
d'ailleurs la saturation du simulateur
de retraite mise à jour hier cette
information claires et fiable c'est
aussi et surtout auprès des personnels
de la Caisse Nationale d'Assurance
vieilles qu'il la trouveront dans les
prochains mois provoquant de fait une
surcharge de travail pour ces agents
alors même que l'arrivée à la retraite
de la génération des baby-boomers
accroît déjà l'activité de la CNAV de 5%
par an et que les effectifs baissent
régulièrement depuis le début des années
2010 je point ainsi prendre l'exemple de
mon département des Yvelines ou des
effectifs sont passés de 41 à 26
collaborateurs au cours des 10 dernières
années monsieur Émilie je comprends
parfaitement et soutien votre volonté de
rendre plus efficient nos services
publics un grand nombre de ces
évolutions passe notamment par la
digitalisation et l'automatisation de
certaines tâches pour permettre aux
agents de se concentrer sur les dossiers
les plus complexes je connais également
votre attachant votre attachement aux
conditions de travail des agents publics
face aux inquiétudes légitimes des
personnes de la cnaves relayées je le
signale de manière constructive et
objective j'aimerais savoir si un plan
spécifique est prévu pour faire face à
l'afflux de demande liées à la réforme
des retraites et ce sur le et sur le
plus long terme quels sont les garanties
que vous pouvez apporter au personnel de
la CNAV quant au maintien des bonnes
conditions de travail je vous remercie
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à madame Carole grand Jean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
millièmes vous interrogez le
gouvernement sur l'entrée en vigueur de
la réforme des retraites ainsi que les
moyens qui y sont mis je vous prie
d'excuser par ailleurs le ministre de du
travail pardon qui est en déplacement ce
jour et qui n'a donc pas pu être avec
nous l'ensemble des services de l'État
et des caisses de retraite sont
pleinement engagés dans ce chantier nous
sommes au rendez-vous de l'application
de la réforme pour qu'elle soit mise en
oeuvre dès le premier septembre vous
l'avez rappelé les premiers décréés ont
été publiés il y a dix jours maintenant
c'est désormais l'écriture d'autres
décrets qui sont en cours je tiens à le
rappeler ceux des régimes spéciaux de la
pénibilité des petites pensions mais
aussi de la transition activité retraite
car au-delà des mesures d'âge se sont
aussi de nouveaux droits que nous
construisons pour nos concitoyens vous
l'avez souligné ce chantier mobilise
tout particulièrement la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse la CNAV
qui bénéficient pour cela de moyens
supplémentaires sans attendre le
déploiement de la réforme nous avons
anticipé bien sûr cette question et
permis à la caisse de recruter déjà plus
de 200 nouveaux collaborateurs nous
avons également souhaité accompagner
cette transformation en confortant des
moyens pour les 5 prochaines années dans
le cadre d'une convention d'objectifs et
de moyens qui leur donne la possibilité
d'avoir une visibilité sur des moyens
qu'ils peuvent engager dans la durée
cette convention d'objectifs et de
moyens elle vient d'être adoptée en
conseil d'administration de la CNAV en
incluant bien sûr le dialogue avec les
partenaires sociaux et elle est
désormais signée elle prévoit notamment
un maintien des effectifs de la CNAV et
le renforcement de 400 CDI
supplémentaires en 2024 ainsi que le
recours à plus de 600 CDD dans la région
Île-de-France la CNAV ce compte près de
2500 experts engagés 25 agences de
proximité 9 points d'accueil retraite et
surtout 160 maisons France services la
totalité de la population francilienne
se je suis donc à moins de 30 minutes
des services de la CNAV c'est évidemment
un point pour nous très important je
vous remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Stéphane Lenorman pour le groupe
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et fait du reste
suite à un certain nombre
d'interrogations que j'avais eu
l'occasion de lui proposer en août
dernier Monsieur le Ministre l'inclusion
scolaire est érigée au rang de priorité
mais est-ce vraiment le cas au regard du
statu quo sur la situation des
accompagnants des élèves en situation de
handicap ou a besoin spécifique ce mardi
les aesh sont de nouveau en grève et
nous alertes sur la précarité de leur
métier pourtant essentiel au dispositif
les avancées se font monsieur le
ministre au compte-goutte vous aviez à
une époque parlée de prise en compte du
temps périscolaire c'est un vrai sujet
et d'ailleurs notre coprésident
Christophe najlaine avait d'ailleurs
déposé une proposition de loi en ce sens
mais le problème est important et les
questions centrales et sont toujours à
mon avis sans réponse je pense en
particulier au temps de travail
réellement effectué en dehors du temps
avec les élèves formation travail avec
les équipes pédagogiques préparation ou
encore l'organisation du temps de
travail qui n'est pas non plus
satisfaisante la mutualisation des aesh
au sein des pôles inclusifs nuit parfois
à l'accompagnement certains sont
contraints de jongler avec plusieurs
établissements enfin nous devons donner
de vraies perspectives de carrière aux
aesh cela implique d'améliorer la
formation mais aussi de valoriser leurs
acquis monsieur le ministre nous sommes
encore bien loin de la juste
reconnaissance du métier d'Ash et la
question de la titularisation doit
pouvoir être étudiée sans tabou
rémunération temps de travail conditions
de travail et formation c'est quatre
enjeux ne doivent plus être traités de
manière séparée elles appellent une
réponse globale car pensez-vous que
l'école puisse être réellement inclusive
son véritable statut d’aesh pour nous au
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoires ce statut est indispensable
à la fois pour les personnels bien sûr
mais aussi et surtout pour les élèves
accompagnés et sur ce sujet monsieur le
ministre il y a eu beaucoup d'annonces
j'aimerais avoir aujourd'hui la position
du gouvernement merci merci beaucoup
passionnel de la jeunesse merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le députés Stéphane
Lenormand la situation économique des
ESH et déterminante pour la qualité de
la scolarisation des élèves en situation
de handicap et donc je partage
évidemment les questions que vous posez
nous avons ces derniers temps fait trois
avancées très importantes qui vont
améliorer de manière nette leur
situation premièrement la loi de
finances 2023 prévoit une augmentation
salariale nette de 10% au 1er septembre
2023 c'était d'ailleurs un amendement
qui a été porté par les groupes
Renaissance modem et horizon c'est une
enveloppe supplémentaire de 80 millions
d'euros pour cette année 2023
deuxièmement cette revalorisation
s'ajoute aux primes réplus qui sont
valables pour les ESH et pour les AED de
fruits depuis le le premier janvier
dernier et enfin après le vote définitif
de la loi Victory les ESH pourront
désormais bénéficier d'un CDI au bout de
trois ans et non au bout de 6 ans avec
la construction d'une carrière par
ailleurs dans le cadre de la Conférence
nationale du handicap le président de la
République le 26 avril dernier a annoncé
un certain nombre d'avancées qui
concernent également les aesh cela passe
notamment par le fait de tendre vers les
35 heures nous le faisons avec les
collectivités territoriales en signant
des conventions qui permettent que
l'État soit employeur unique les
abaissages font 35 heures avec un temps
scolaire et un temps périscolaire et ce
sont les collectivités qui nous
rembourse du temps périscolaire nous
souhaitons aller plus loin leur proposer
des missions notamment en lien avec la
vie scolaire pour que la situation des
a.sa s'améliore nous travaillons
également à leur formation 60 heures ça
n'est pas suffisant de manière à ce que
nous puissions améliorer et progresser
ensemble pour les absh merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Julien Rancoule
pour le rassemblement national
merci Madame la Ministre ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Intérieur
dans un an la France aura l'honneur
d'accueillir les Jeux Olympiques pour la
troisième fois de son histoire dans le
même temps le défi de la sécurité privée
pour les JO n'a jamais semblé aussi
difficile à relever
25000 agents de sécurité privée doivent
encore être recrutés monsieur le
ministre selon la Fédération nationale
de la sécurité privée la filière déplore
déjà un déficit structurel de 20000
agents au quotidien les sociétés
préféreront toujours assurer les
prestations pour leurs clients réguliers
plutôt qu'un contrat de quelques
semaines pour les JO la preuve les lots
des appels d'offres auprès des
entreprises de la branche ne sont pas
tous pourvus
pourtant cet événement historique était
l'opportunité rêvée de moderniser et de
valoriser les métiers de la sécurité
humaine
ou en est le fameux continuum de
sécurité associé à la sécurité publique
et la sécurité privée
plutôt que d'avoir une vision à long
terme pour la profession vous avez créé
une carte professionnelle surveillance
grand événements mais qui va passer une
formation de 106 heures valable un an
pour travailler deux semaines au SMIC
croyez-vous vraiment que cela va
permettre de recruter les 25000 agents
manquants deuxième et dernière de vos
mesures madame la ministre des Sports
voulaient chercher des agents de
sécurité privée chez dans les pays
francophones quelles méconnaissance
totale du sujet quand on sait qu'ils
sont payés 50% plus cher en Belgique et
je ne vous parle même pas de la Suisse
monsieur le ministre nous ne voulons pas
revivre le l'humiliation de la finale de
la Ligue de des champions de l'an
dernier vous aviez déjà failli à votre
mission
alors que les professionnels considèrent
déjà qu'il est déjà trop tard sur le
sujet Comment allez-vous trouver les
25000 agents de sécurité dans la France
a réellement besoin pour eux encadrer
les Jeux Olympiques et quand allez-vous
réellement prendre en considération les
50000 agents de sécurité présent sur
notre territoire je vous remercie merci
beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer merci la présidente de
Monsieur député monsieur le député je
veux d'abord comme vous l'avez fait
m'associer au reconnaît la
reconnaissance légitime que nous avons
pour les agents de sécurité privée il
faut un travail difficile il faut un
travail essentiel et il faut un travail
évidemment important aujourd'hui demain
pour la Coupe du monde de rugby que nous
accueillons dès le mois de septembre et
bien sûr pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques et permettez-moi d'être
interrogatif par rapport à votre
question si nous avons plus de mal à
recruter les agents de sécurité privée
si vous avez créé de nouvelles cartes
parce que nous sommes plus exigeants
j'aimerais connaître la position du
rassemblement national lorsque le
gouvernement a décidé de ne plus mettre
des personnes
qui ne parlent pas français
qui doivent passer par tous les services
de renseignement pour qu'on puisse
valider l'engagement professionnel et
par ailleurs qui doit être là depuis
plus de 5 ans sur le territoire national
êtes-vous d'accord avec ces mesures que
nous avons prises est-ce que vous
acceptez donc monsieur le député que
nous puissions être plus exigeants parce
qu'il se pourrait il se pourrait
monsieur le député
il se pourrait monsieur le député de la
parole est libre monsieur député je sais
que j'ai pas l'occasion de répondre
souvent à vos arguments démagogiques et
je me permets donc de retourner
puisqu'il y a quelques secondes il se
pourrait que vous soyez soyez à la fois
pyromane et pompiers souhaitant avoir
plus d'exigences avec le secteur et en
même temps nous reprocher dans
l'intelligence pour le secteur
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre mon
cher collègue allez-y écoutez monsieur
le ministre encore une fois vous
répondez à côté si vous manquez d'agent
de sécurité c'est parce que vous avez
des dizaines d'agents de sécurité qui
sont détenteurs de la carte
professionnelle qui ont quitté la
profession parce que c'est un métier qui
dévalorisé merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre
pile je
critiquer que d'apporter des
propositions je constate que vous ne
répondez jamais à aucune à aucune
responsabilité la vérité monsieur le
député c'est que nous travaillons à
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques avec
l'ensemble des agents de sécurité il y a
des augmentations de salaires par
branche une première augmentation qui
est très importante nous encourageons
les entreprises des augmenter
manifestement vous les connaissez
n'hésitez pas à dire à mieux payer leurs
salariés ce serait une bonne chose soyez
du côté des ouvriers de la sécurité
moins du côté des patrons je vous
remercier Monsieur le Ministre
la parole
s'il vous plaît la parole est à Monsieur
Eric à lozet pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Fonction publique Stanislas Guérini
monsieur le ministre les fonctionnaires
comme l'ensemble des Français sont
confrontés à une érosion de leur pouvoir
d'achat et de leur reste à vivre en
raison de l'inflation galopante apparue
avec la reprise économique postcoïde
puis la guerre en Ukraine cette
inflation en particulier sur les
produits alimentaires pèsent sur les
salaires les plus bas et précarisent
certains ménages qui peinent à joindre
les deux bouts les témoignages ne
manquent pas sur ma circonscription
aussi le gouvernement vient d'annoncer
une série de hausses de rémunération
avec un effort particulier en faveur des
plus modestes les catégories B et
surtout les catégories C dans les
différentiels de salaires avec le SMIC
se réduit ainsi les hausses générales
seront complétées par des attributions
de points d'indice plus favorables au
bas salaire des hausses qu'il convient
donc d'apprécier non pas seulement sur
la base de l'augmentation générale du
point de 1,5% mais en prenant en compte
les dispositifs spécifiques dédiés aux
catégories B et surtout C mais pour cela
il faut un peu d'objectivité et se
départir de la mauvaise foi manifestée
ici même au début de cette séance lors
d'une question de la nups
au total ce ne sont pas à moi de 3,5
milliards d'euros qui seront engagés dès
cette année et 6 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires l'année prochaine pour
revaloriser les salaires de nos
fonctionnaires après les 7,5 milliards
de juillet 2022 aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pourriez-vous nous détailler
l'ensemble des mesures que vous avez
annoncé au partenaires sociaux sans
attendre pour le pouvoir d'achat des
fonctionnaires merci beaucoup mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Stanislas Guerini ministre de la
transformation et de la fonction
publique merci
députés monsieur le député avec alosé
vous avez raison de souligner que
l'inflation est en train de décélérer
elle est la plus faible d'Europe le
gouvernement s'engage et combat cette
inflation les agrégoire là encore
rappelé mais le reste forte en
particulier sur l'alimentaire et elle a
des conséquences très concrètes elle
impacte de plein fouet les plus bas
niveau de rémunération c'est vrai dans
le privé c'est vrai dans le public et
puis elle entraîne une dynamique sur le
salaire minimum que nous ajustons
systématiquement dans la fonction
publique
aussi avec des conséquences concrètes
parfois un effet de non progressivité
des carrières d'écrasement des grilles
il est bien connu de tous les employeurs
publics et puis aussi un niveau d'agent
qui sont rémunérés au niveau du SMIC et
plus important du fait de cette
dynamique du salaire minimum dans le
pays ça c'est la situation alors nous
avons pris nos responsabilités nous on
fait dans la concertation j'ai réuni
avec ma collègue Dominique Faure
l'ensemble des associations d'élus dans
le dialogue social avec les
organisations syndicales et nous avons
assumé à la fois de mettre des moyens
importants vous l'avez rappelé 3,5
milliards d'euros sur le deuxième
semestre 6 milliards d'euros on a les
plaines mais de concentrer ces moyens
sur les plus bas niveau de rémunération
c'est ce que nous faisons quand nous
versons des points d'indice à l'ensemble
des agences à plus d'impact sur les
agents de Bad grill nous versons des
points d'indice en particulier sur les
débuts de catégorie C et les débuts de
catégorie B justement pour redonner de
la progressivité au carrière et j'assume
effectivement de débloquer une prime de
pouvoir d'achat pour l'ensemble des
agents qui seront rémunérés et qui sont
rémunérés en dessous de 3250 euros brut
de rémunération et puis le pouvoir
d'achat ce sont des mesures salariales
je viens d'en faire la démonstration
sont aussi des décisions très concrètes
quand nous décidons nous l'avons fait
que le ministre de transport de
revaloriser la prise en charge des
transports en commun ça a des
conséquences très concrètes dans le
portefeuille pour un agent français bien
son passe Navigo quand ça a remboursé de
50 à 75%, c'est 20 euros par mois vous
le voyez nous prenons nos
responsabilités et nos agissons pour les
basses salaires et les classes moyennes
dans la fonction publique merci monsieur
le ministre monsieur le député oui merci
merci pour vos explications monsieur le
ministre nous pouvons évidemment
comprendre que parfois les français
demandent plus espèrent plus mais il
faut aussi savoir aussi savoir saluer
les efforts qui sont faits merci merci
beaucoup mon cher collègue la parole est
à Madame Élise le boucher pour la France
insoumise
monsieur le ministre de la Santé
Saint-Nazaire une unité pour adolescent
et une unité d'admission fermée Blin 17
lits fermés Allonnes 42 lits fermés
Laval Rennes Marseille Toulouse
Draguignan la liste est bien trop longue
voici les modalises infirmière en
psychiatrie 42 c'est le nombre de lits
qui ont fermé à l'hôpital psy en Sarthe
42 c'est mon âge pas si vieille
direz-vous mais un dinosaure dans mon
métier 18 ans de bons et loyaux services
l'accueil inconditionnel l'empathie
l'échange l'asile aux pivulnérables la
réflexion autant de choses de venir
indésirables dans nos hôpitaux le
tornover le flux patient les cases
managers les bêtes bloqueurs voilà de
quoi nous parlons maintenant monsieur le
ministre il n'y a pas que les soignants
et les médecins qui tirent la sonnette
d'alarme la Cour des comptes dont on ne
peut dont on ne peut pas dire qu'elle
soit insoumises pointe aussi votre
manque de volonté politique dans les
moyens attribués à la psychiatrie et à
la pédopsie en particulier
surtout le territoire la solidarité
régionale ne fonctionne plus
l'ambulatoire Saturne une équation
insoluble parce qu'elle laisse une
inconnue comment sortir de cet état de
crise permanent et surtout comment
soigner avec humanité comme l'a dit m'a
dit pano hier à la tribune votre monde
est devenu un océan de malheur avec ses
conséquences stéries pour des milliers
de gens qui n'arrivent plus à surmonter
le quotidien pénible et l'avenir
assombri la situation de détresse que
vous provoquez en psychiatrie et
symptomatique par tous les conséquences
de vos mauvais choix politiques font
reculer l'accès aux soins et les prises
en charge dans les EHPAD à l'ASE les
prisons l'école la justice partout les
services publics reculent l'humain
recule c'est le résultat de votre action
politique et celle de vos prédécesseurs
depuis la tarification à l'acte et
l'ONDAM vous avez imposé l'idéologie
néolibéral dans notre système de santé
contre la Villa communauté soignante
vous avez transformé le soin en
marchandise et source de profit pour vos
amis les plus riches et en maltraitance
pour les soignants et les patients cette
politique nous mène droit dans le mur
alors Monsieur le Ministre aurez-vous le
courage de rendre le PSM de la Sarthe
c'est 42 lits de rendre à l'hôpital ce
que vous lui avez pris de porter un réel
plan d'urgence pour la psychiatrie si
vous ne le souhaitez pas passer la main
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès tient mal au Bodo au ministre
délégué chargé de l'organisation
territoriale et des professions de santé
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
le boucher je tiens à le réaffirmer
l'importance que nous accordons à la
santé mentale et la psychiatrie il
s'agit de déterminant majeurs de cette
santé globale que nous défendons je
n'ignore pas le climat actuel
d'inquiétude face aux difficultés fortes
auxquelles font face la psychiatrie
particulièrement dans le secteur public
je sais combien la crise sanitaire a mis
en avant cet enjeu notamment chez les
plus jeunes je sais aussi combien cet
enjeu a pu malheureusement être mis en
lumière dans le contexte de drame récent
et parfois instrumentalisé madame la
députée je tiens à vous rassurer le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé sur
le sujet c'est une priorité de notre
politique de santé et de prévention
depuis 2018 nous avons engagé une
feuille de route ambitieuse elle a été
enrichie en 2021 des mesures annoncées
par le Président de la République aux
Assises de la santé mentale et de la
psychiatrie ce sont près de 50 mesures
qui sont sous la supervision du délégué
ministériel le professeur Franck
Bélivier nous avons fait un bilan
d'étape de la feuille de route en mars
dernier devant les acteurs concernés
sans niait les difficultés les choses
avancent lancement de campagne de
communication pour distigmatiser la
santé mentale développement de la
prévention avec le développement des
compétences psychosociales à l'école des
actions de prévention du suicide avec le
numéro national 31 14 ou encore le
dispositif vigilance amélioration de la
prise en charge de près de 90 000
patients grâce à 300 000 consultations
mon parcours psy dont 20% des mineurs
enfin renforcement des centres
médico-psychologiques et des maisons des
adolescents présents depuis fin 2022
dans tous les départements allongement
de la formation en psychiatrie et
augmentation des postes hachu en
pédopsychiatrie développement des IPA en
psychiatrie ou encore travaux des
assises de l'enfant bien sûr ce n'est
pas encore suffisant et beaucoup reste à
faire nous nous y employons activement
la santé mentale doit être reconnue
comme complaisante indissociable de la
santé globale à ce titre la santé
mentale sera prise en compte de manière
renforcée dans la mise en oeuvre
prochaine des bilans de prévention aux
ashes clés et dans la prochaine
stratégie nationale de santé merci
beaucoup madame la ministre la séance de
questions au Gouvernement est terminée
la séance est suspendue